I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Lady Luck, roll those dice, it's Casino Night, everyone. Oh, baby.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们一起演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们就是《办公室》。幸运女神，掷出骰子，今晚是赌场之夜，各位。哦，宝贝。
Yes, it is. I'm so excited for this episode. I had not watched this since it aired until we prepped for this episode. And Angela, oh my gosh, it is so good. It is. I saw God really quickly before we get started, you guys. You know, we're recording from home right now and it's pouring rain. So if you hear some rain, that is why.
没错，就是这样。我太兴奋了。自从这集播出以来，直到我们为这集做准备，我一直没有看过。安吉拉，哦天哪，它太棒了。确实如此。在我们开始之前，你们大家，我真的差点看到上帝了。你知道的，我们现在是在家里录音，外面正下着倾盆大雨。所以如果你听到一些雨声，那就是原因所在。
Yeah, I had to move into my daughter's closet because the rain outside of my closet, it kind of sounded like I was tinkling the whole time. I didn't want it to sound like inappropriate. I mean, I know there's rain, but then you know how sometimes the rain happens to come off of a gutter in a sort of waterfall-esque way? Apparently, that's what happens outside of my closet. So I'm in my daughter's closet. Well, I'm in my that's what she said because all three kids are inside and they are so
是的，我不得不搬进我女儿的衣橱里，因为衣橱外面的雨声听起来就像我一直在尿尿一样。我不想让它听起来不合时宜。我的意思是，我知道外面在下雨，但你知道有时雨水从屋顶排水沟流下来时，会形成一种类似瀑布的方式吗？显然，这就是我衣橱外面的情况。所以我才待在我女儿的衣橱里。好吧，我待在我的是她说的里，因为三个孩子都在里面，而且他们太
loud. And I'm just like, what? I can't tell them to like not make any noise ever. Yeah. Okay. So here we go. Casino night. I'm so excited.
吵了。我简直不知所措，我不能让他们永远不发出任何声音。好吧。那么，我们开始吧。赌场之夜。我太兴奋了。
Season two, episode 22, written by Steve Carell. Steve Carell. All right. Written by Steve Carell, directed by Ken Quapas. This is already off to a good start, Jenna. Oh yeah. This is a good team. All right.
第二季第二十二集，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。好的，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧，肯·夸帕斯执导。这个开局很不错，珍娜。哦，是的。这是一个很好的团队。好啦。
Hit me with a summary. Here we go. Michael decides to hold a casino night down in the warehouse to benefit charity. However, Michael is going to have to juggle two dates. Bum, bum, bum. Also Jim is dealing with his possible transfer to the Stanford branch. Yeah. And that's going to lead him to ponder his relationship with Pam.
用一段总结来考考我吧。我们开始吧。迈克尔决定在仓库里举办一个赌场之夜来为慈善事业筹款。然而，迈克尔将不得不脚踩两条船。咚，咚，咚。还有，吉姆正在处理他可能调到斯坦福分公司的事。是的。这将引导他对与帕姆的关系进行思考。
It's a good one. Should we get into some Sam? Fast facts. Yeah. Fast facts. Fast facts, number one, written by Steve Carell. So here's something that maybe a lot of people don't know. Steve also co-wrote 40-year-old virgin.
这是一个不错的选择。我们要不要聊点山姆？快讯。是的。快讯。快讯一，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧。所以这里有一点可能很多人都不知道。史蒂夫还联合编剧了《四十岁的老处男》。
This is not the first thing that Steve has written. So he got to write this episode. You know, he also wrote another episode of The Office, season four, episode seven, Survivor Man. So we'll get to that one. But I found an old article from the LA Times, where Steve did an interview all of about how he came to be the writer of this season two finale.
这不是史蒂夫写的第一部作品。所以他得到了编写这一集的任务。你知道的，他还写了《办公室》的另一集，第四季第七集，《荒岛求生》。所以我们会聊到那一集。但我发现了一篇《洛杉矶时报》的旧文章，里面史蒂夫接受了采访，详细讲述了他如何成为这一季季终集编剧的过程。
Lady, that is some good detective work. I love it. I was very proud of myself. All right, so here's how it went down. So Steve had the idea as a general episode that Michael should throw a casino night down in the warehouse. And he pitched that idea to Greg and Greg said, oh, that would make a great setting for the finale episode.
女士，你这侦探工作做得真不错。我喜欢。我为自己感到骄傲。好吧，事情是这样的。史蒂夫有一个常规剧集的构思，那就是迈克尔应该在仓库里举办一个赌场之夜。他把这个构思向格雷格进行了推销，格雷格说，哦，这将是作为季终集的一个绝佳背景。
And then, I guess, remember when Steve had to fly to New York to do the Valentine's Day episode? Yeah. On the airplane, Steve and Greg were together. And on the way there and on the way back, they sat down. They sort of plotted out together what the finale would be with this casino night idea. Oh, my god, that's amazing.
然后，我猜，还记得史蒂夫不得不飞往纽约去拍摄情人节那一集的时候吗？是的。在飞机上，史蒂夫和格雷格在一起。在去程和回程的路上，他们坐在一起。他们一起规划了以这个赌场之夜构思为基础的季终集会是什么样的。哦，天哪，这太棒了。
Because they're on the plane and they're outlining this episode. I love that. And Greg said to Steve, why don't you write it? You should write it. And Steve was like, OK, yeah, I mean, I think that's great. But then this is a really fun tidbit. Steve got cold feet. And he tried to get out of it.
因为他们在飞机上勾勒这一集的轮廓。我太喜欢这个了。格雷格对史蒂夫说，你为什么不自己写呢？你应该写。史蒂夫当时觉得，好吧，行，我的意思是，我觉得这挺好。但接着，这是一个非常有趣的趣闻。史蒂夫临阵退缩了。他想逃避。
So I guess this was during the time when he was still doing Evan Almighty on the weekends. He would shoot on our show sometimes like four days a week. We would shoot him out in four days. And then he would fly. And on the weekends, he would be doing Evan Almighty. And so he flew home and he had one weekend to write this finale script.
所以我想这正是在他周末还在拍摄《冒牌天神2》的那段时间。他有时一周有四天在我们的节目中拍摄。我们会在四天内拍完他的戏份。然后他会飞走。到了周末，他就在拍《冒牌天神2》。所以他飞回家，只有一个周末的时间来写这个季终集的剧本。
And his parents were in town visiting him at his house. And so he went into Greg's office. And he said, I just don't think I can do it justice. There's no way I can do it. I should get out of it. But Steve had this great quote where he said, I don't know, Greg managed to talk him into doing it anyway.
当时他的父母正在他家里探望他。于是他走进了格雷格的办公室。他说，我只是觉得我无法把它写好。我根本没办法完成。我应该退出。但史蒂夫有一句很棒的话，他说，我不知道，格雷格还是说服了他继续写下去。
Like, Greg has a way where by the time he was leaving Greg's office, he was like, I'm writing this episode again. How did that happen? I should not get out of it. So that makes me smile because it's very Greg. Greg, we've sort of all said that he was kind of like our dad. Yeah. Although he's not old enough to be our dad, obviously.
就像，格雷格有一种方式，当他离开格雷格的办公室时，他会想，我又要写这一集了。怎么会这样？我不应该退出的。这让我笑了，因为这非常格雷格。格雷格，我们之前都说过他有点像我们的爸爸。是的。尽管他显然还没有老到可以当我们的爸爸。
But he had sort of that father mentor thing of like, you figure it out. You're going to do it. It's going to be OK. And then you're like, wait, what? It's going to be great. Wait, I can totally see that. I came in here to tell you I'm not doing it.
但他身上有一种父亲兼导师的气质，意思是，你自己去搞定。你会做到的。一切都会好起来的。然后你会想，等等，什么？这会很棒的。等等，我完全能理解。我来这里是想告诉你我不会做的。
And now I'm writing it. Yeah. But he did say he was really pumped. Like, that was the other part of it was that Greg really infused him with this enthusiasm. So he was really excited. So what he did was he went home and he would write the script after his parents went to bed.
而现在我在写了。是的。但他确实说过他真的很兴奋。这就是另一部分原因，格雷格确实把这种热情注入了他体内。所以他真的很兴奋。所以他做的事就是回家，等父母睡着后写剧本。
Aw. So he would stay up at night and write the script. And he turned it in. And he said then the writing staff did a bunch of punch ups. And like they usually do. Right. And that's how we got the script. Wow.
啊。所以他会熬夜写剧本，然后交了上去。他说接着编剧团队做了一堆润色，像他们平时做的那样。没错。这就是我们拿到剧本的过程。哇。
Way to go, Steve. Way to go. Isn't that crazy? Man, I love that story. All right, that was a good one. Moving on to Fast Fact number two. This is a super-sized episode. Greg said that he was doing an interview for the Chicago
干得好，史蒂夫。干得好。是不是很疯狂？天哪，我太喜欢这个故事了。好吧，那是一个不错的。接下来是快讯二。这是一集加长版。格雷格说他当时正在接受《芝加哥》报的采访
Tribune. And he had mentioned in the interview kind of casually that he wished that the finale for season two could be super-sized. Well, this started a whole online petition by office fans. They started writing in like crazy to NBC. Give me my remote. Northern Attack and Office Tally started these online petitions.
论坛报。他在采访中随口提到，他希望第二季的季终集能做成加长版。好吧，这引发了办公室粉丝们在网上的全体请愿。他们开始疯狂地给全国广播公司写信。把我的遥控器交出来。北方袭击和办公室计分板发起了这些网络请愿。
And it was the fans that got us the super-sized episode. That's great. And you know what? This was before Twitter and Instagram. It was not easy to start an online petition back then. Yeah, no. You didn't have the same outreach. And they really just like kept at it.
正是粉丝们为我们争取到了加长版。太棒了。你知道吗？这还是在推特和Instagram出现之前。那时候发起网络请愿可不容易。对，没错。你没有相同的宣传渠道。而他们真的只是坚持不懈。
And NBC was like, OK. Greg was thrilled. Thank you so much to the office fans for making that happen because I could not imagine this episode being 22 minutes. There's so much we would have missed. I wish this episode was an hour. I could have watched even more.
全国广播公司就同意了，好吧。格雷格欣喜若狂。非常感谢办公室粉丝们让这一切成为现实，因为我无法想象这一集只有22分钟。会有那么多我们错过的内容。我希望这一集是一个小时。我本可以看更多的。
I know. But I kind of feel like that about almost all the episodes. But this one in particular, I'm so happy it was longer. That's what she said. That's what she said. Well, speaking of longer, this podcast is probably also going to be super-sized today because, well, we're going to have a special guest join us later.
我知道。但我几乎对所有剧集都有这种感觉。但唯独这一集，我太高兴它能更长了。她就是这么说的。她就是这么说的。好吧，说到更长，这个播客今天可能也会是加长版的，因为，好吧，稍后会有一位特别嘉宾加入我们。
Jenna and I got to talk to someone about this episode. And this person was such a delight. Jenna, we talked for almost an hour. We did. And we just want you guys to hear it all. So buckle in. It's going to be a super-sized episode. It is.
我和安吉拉有机会和某人聊了聊这一集。这个人简直太讨人喜欢了。珍娜，我们聊了将近一个小时。确实如此。我们只想让你们听到全部内容。所以系好安全带。这将是一个加长版。是的。
It's going to be jam-packed. Bum, bum, bum. Wink, wink. Fastback number three. We got a lot of questions from fans about what it was like to transform the warehouse into a casino. I mean, seriously, can we talk about this for a second?
内容会非常丰富。咚，咚，咚。眨眼，眨眼。快讯三。我们收到了粉丝们的大量提问，关于把仓库改造成赌场是什么样的体验。我的意思是，说真的，我们能谈谈这个一会儿吗？
Can we talk about Dunder Mifflin's budget for parties? I mean, as head of the party planning committee, I usually had some streamers and a cake. I mean, and one plastic tablecloth. It's true. But then Michael takes us on a booze cruise. He throws us this casino night. Where is he getting the money for this?
我们能谈谈邓德米夫林的派对预算吗？我的意思是，作为派对策划委员会的主任，我通常只有一些彩带和一个蛋糕。我的意思是，还有一张塑料桌布。确实如此。但随后迈克尔带我们去了一次酒水游轮。他给我们办了这个赌场之夜。他的钱是从哪里来的？
At eight seconds, Jenna, you see them converting the warehouse. And there's all these extra employees. There's giant neon signs. There's dealers. I mean, where is this budget coming from? That I don't know. That I don't know. But I did reach out to Kentopedia
在八秒钟的时候，珍娜，你看到他们在改造仓库。有这么多额外的员工。有巨大的霓虹灯招牌。有荷官。我的意思是，这个预算是从哪里来的？这个我不知道。这个我不知道。但我确实联系了肯百科
to find out how we transformed the warehouse into a casino. And this is what he said. He said that he hired a company that specialized in creating casinos for special events, like Christmas parties or college fundraisers. I've been to those things. I've been to fundraisers that are casino nights. And so there are these companies, and they send dealers.
来了解我们是如何将仓库改造成赌场的。他是这么说的。他说他雇了一家专门为特殊活动（如圣诞派对或大学募捐活动）创建赌场的公司。我去过那种地方。我去过赌场之夜的募捐活动。所以有这样的公司，他们会派遣荷官。
They send all the equipment. And so he just said he hired one of those companies. And then he used all the employees from the company as extras in the episode. What was this budget? I'm sorry, I can't stop talking about the budget. But it was crazy. Do you think we raised more money than the party cost?
他们发送所有的设备。所以他只是说他雇了其中一家公司。然后他用了该公司所有的员工作为这一集的群众演员。这是什么预算？对不起，我停不下来谈论预算。但这太疯狂了。你觉得我们筹到的钱比派对的花费还多吗？
No. No. It was definitely a loss. It was a loss, for sure. Speaking of the whole casino setup, fan question from Explorin' Lauren. She asked, in between scenes, did you all play any poker games? Did you, Amj?
没有。没有。这绝对是亏本的。这绝对是亏本。说到整个赌场设置，探索劳伦的粉丝提问。她问，在场景之间，你们都玩过扑克牌吗？你玩了吗，阿姆杰？
Did you play any of the games? No, I didn't. Did you? Oh, yeah. You did? Oh, yeah. There were any time that I was living. Well, you love poker.
你玩过那些游戏吗？不，我没有。你呢？哦，是的。你玩过？哦，是的。任何我活着的时候。好吧，你喜欢扑克。
I know. And it was professional dealers. So my character was stationed at the poker tables, too. So whenever I was in the background of any scenes, I was sitting at a poker table and we played poker. It was the greatest time, the best time. I mean, I have a memory of sitting and watching you guys play cards, because I really didn't know how to play poker.
我知道。而且那是专业的荷官。所以我的角色也被安排在扑克桌旁。因此，每当我出现在任何场景的背景中时，我都坐在扑克桌旁，我们打扑克。那是最好的时光，最美好的时光。我的意思是，我有坐着看你们打牌的记忆，因为我真的不会打扑克。
I only just learned. I'm not great. I mean, I always think I can win with a pair of threes. I'm that. I'm basically Phyllis. You can? I know. But I'm basically Phyllis.
我刚刚学会。我不太擅长。我的意思是，我总是以为一对三就能赢。我就是那种人。我基本上就是菲利斯。你能吗？我知道。但我基本上就是菲利斯。
Like, oh, look, the one with the flower won. Clovers. The clovers. But a lot of you guys were poker players. I mean, Rain had a poker tournament, didn't he, in his garage or something? You guys all went? Yeah.
就像，哦，看，那个带花的赢了。三叶草。三叶草。但你们很多人都是扑克玩家。我的意思是，雷恩举办过扑克锦标赛，不是吗，在他的车库里什么的？你们都去了吗？是的。
The people who played the most together outside of work were me, Rain, David Denman, Chris Workman, and Ed Nielsen Jr. Those guys were on the crew. And I'm trying to think who else. But there was a little group of us, like six or eight of us, and we would go to Rain's garage and play poker on the weekends. Yeah. So I love that you guys were doing that in between scenes.
工作之余聚在一起玩得最多的人是我、雷恩、大卫·丹曼、克里斯·沃克曼和埃尔·尼尔森二世。那些人都在剧组里。我在想要还有谁。但我们有一个小团体，大概六八个人，我们会在周末去雷恩的车库打扑克。是的，所以我喜欢你们在场景之间做这个。
I'm sure I just was sitting there being chatty. Well, listen, I think we should take a break and get into this episode. Because like we said, it's a long one. So we'll be right back. [?]. OK, we are back. And let's get into this episode, Jenna.
我确信我当时只是坐在那里聊天。好吧，听着，我想我们应该休息一下，然后进入这一集。因为正如我们所说，这是一个很长的故事。所以我们马上回来。[？]。好的，我们回来了。让我们进入这一集吧，珍娜。
We've got a lot of ground to cover. And at 36 seconds, Dwight's in a tuxedo. Game on. It's starting. Oh, yeah. He explains that it's a family heirloom. His grandfather was buried in it. Yeah, so that's special.
我们有很多内容要涵盖。在36秒时，德怀特穿着燕尾服。比赛开始。开始了。哦，是的。他解释说这是一件传家宝。他的祖父母穿着它下葬。是的，所以这很特别。
And now you have a Jim Pam prank, right? Can we talk for one quick second about the fact that Pam winks at Jim with Roy right there? I have that down. I have that down. So yes, Roy and Pam, they're talking about Casino Night. This starts a whole conversation about who can win roulette. Jim says he can win by using mind control.
现在你有一个吉姆和帕姆的恶作剧，对吧？我们能花一秒钟谈谈帕姆在罗伊就在旁边的情况下对吉姆抛媚眼的事吗？我记下了。我记下了。所以是的，罗伊和帕姆，他们在谈论赌场之夜。这引发了一场关于谁能在轮盘赌中获胜的对话。吉姆说他可以通过使用精神控制来获胜。
And Dwight says, oh, really? You can do mind control. Why don't you try moving the coat wrap? So he stares at it, and it moves to everyone's surprise. And then Pam winks at Jim. And I wrote down, discuss, how do we feel about this? It's a big wink. It's not like, and Roy is right there.
德怀特说，哦，真的吗？你会精神控制。你为什么不试着移动那个大衣架？于是他盯着它看，在所有人的惊讶中，它移动了。然后帕姆对吉姆抛了个媚眼。我写下了，讨论一下，我们对此感觉如何？这是一个很大的媚眼。不像那样，而且罗伊就在旁边。
Is he, yeah, does he not have eyes? Is he not? Is Roy looking at his fiance? What the hell? Why are you winking at Jim? So the flirt is starting early on. This is early. For sure.
是吗，是的，他没有眼睛吗？他不是吗？罗伊在看他的未婚妻吗？搞什么鬼？你为什么对吉姆抛媚眼？所以调情很早就开始了。这很早。肯定的。
Early in the evening. It's not even the evening. It's the day. The flirt is starting. I had a fan question from Batya who said, was the wink Pam gave Jim scripted? Yes, it was. I was going to say, absolutely.
傍晚刚开始。甚至还不是傍晚。是白天。调情开始了。我有一个来自巴蒂亚的粉丝提问，她说，帕姆给吉姆的那个媚眼是剧本里写好的吗？是的，是的。我本想说，绝对是的。
It was. It was in the script. I actually, I have the script from this episode, Angela. I love that you have the script. So you could go to it. Yeah, I looked it up, and it's right there. It says, Pam winks at Jim. I had another fan question, too, from Brittany.
是的。剧本里写了。实际上，我有这一集的剧本，安吉拉。我很高兴你有剧本。所以你可以去查。是的，我查了，就在那里。上面写着，帕姆对吉姆抛媚眼。我还有一个粉丝提问，来自布兰妮。
In the cold open, Jenna, did you actually move the coat wrap with an umbrella? No. No. No. And Jenna, what? In a time capsule called the DVD commentary, you talk about it.
在开场白中，珍娜，你真的用雨伞移动了大衣架吗？没有。没有。没有。珍娜，什么？在名为DVD评论的时光胶囊中，你谈到了它。
Oh, I went into it? Yeah, you went into it. You said that there was a crew member that had a string. It was like a clear fishing line. We tried to have me do it. We tried to have me use the little, even like, tried to have me use that string thing. And you just saw my arm moving too much.
哦，我深入探讨了？是的，你深入探讨了。你说过有一个剧组人员有一根线。就像一根透明的钓鱼线。我们试图让我做。我们试图让我使用那个小的，甚至试图让我使用那个带线的玩意儿。然后你只能看到我的胳膊动得太多了。
I was too far away. Like, the umbrella with the hook on the end, it couldn't, I couldn't even reach the coat wrap with it. I was going to say, the coat wrap is actually further away from you than people realize. Yeah. It's actually quite far from you. But the optical illusion makes it kind of seem like I could have.
我离得太远了。就像，末端带钩子的雨伞，它不能，我甚至用它够不到大衣架。我要说的是，大衣架实际上比人们意识到的离你更远。是的。它实际上离你很远。但视觉错觉让人觉得我好像能做到。
But no, I wasn't really doing it. And then Pam is very proud of herself, because she has a silent talking head where she's showing off the umbrella. And Jenna, you're like, as Pam, you are beaming. You are so proud of that moment. I know. Well, I think it's meant, you know,
但没有，我真的没做。然后帕姆为自己感到非常自豪，因为她有一个无声的采访，她在炫耀雨伞。珍娜，你就像，作为帕姆，你在发光。你为那一刻感到非常自豪。我知道。好吧，我认为这是故意的，
that wasn't set up, that whole idea of mind control. I think the idea of that was that in the moment, Pam figured out how to have Jim's back. Yeah. And so I think she's like, that's where the wink comes from. And that's why she's so proud. Exactly. She's super proud.
那个精神控制的整个想法并不是事先安排好的。我认为那个想法是，在那一刻，帕姆想出了如何支持吉姆。是的。所以我想这就是媚眼来源的地方。这就是为什么她如此骄傲。没错。她超级骄傲。
They didn't know Dwight was going to pick the coat wrap. Pam didn't know that Jim was going to set that up. So yeah, she's like, look what I did. Oh my god. I know. I had another fan question, Angela. This is from Chelsea Glover. Were there any deleted scenes that you're sad
他们不知道德怀特会挑中大衣架。帕姆不知道吉姆会那样安排。所以，是的，她就像，看我做了什么。哦，天哪。我知道。我还有另一个粉丝提问，安吉拉。这是来自切尔西·格洛弗的。有没有什么被删减的场景让你感到遗憾
didn't make the final cut? And actually, there is an original cold open to this episode. This little prank bit with the coat wrap, this was actually originally meant to go after the credit sequence. And there's a whole cold open that was cut out, but that you can see on the DVD extras. Did you watch it, Angela?
没有进入最终剪辑？实际上，这一集有一个最初的开场。这个关于大衣架的小恶作剧片段，最初其实是打算放在演职员表序列之后的。还有一个完整的开场被剪掉了，但你可以在DVD花絮上看到。你看过吗，安吉拉？
It's where Michael brings us into the conference room and makes us do a Dunder Mifflin themed mad lib. Mad Libs. Yes. It's great. Yeah. So I thought that was kind of cool, but we had enough time. So we had to cut it out.
那是迈克尔把我们带进会议室，让我们做一个邓德米夫林主题的疯狂填词。疯狂填词。是的。太棒了。是的，我觉得这挺酷的，但我们时间不够。所以我们不得不把它剪掉。
Well, listen, I have a pretty big thing to point out. I'm pretty sure a lot of you guys were thinking about it. You're going to be talking about it. It's kind of a showstopper moment. What is it? At three minutes, one second, there's a new plant at reception. A new potted plant. There is a yellow flowering plant at reception.
好吧，听着，我有一个相当大的点要指出来。我很确定你们中的很多人都在想这个。你们会谈论这个。这有点像一个惊艳全场的时刻。是什么？在三分一秒，前台多了一株植物。一盆新植物。前台有一株开黄花的植物。
This is a big deal, guys. We got so much mail about this. We got no mail about it. I always crack up whenever Pam. I feel like it's Pam brings in a plant, and then it doesn't live very long, but she tries. That's my backstory. She tries to, it's like Casino Night.
这是一件大事，伙计们。我们收到了大量关于这个的信件。我们没有收到任何关于它的信件。每当帕姆出现时，我总是咯咯笑。我觉得这就是帕姆带进来一株植物，然后它活不了多久，但她尽力了。这就是我的背景故事。她尽力了，就像赌场之夜。
I'll buy a plant at the pharmacy. They have those plants by the checkout. I'll buy one. She's doing her best. She's trying to bring some cheer to the reception desk. Well, we have the scene where Michael is on the phone with Jan. She's trying to explain her concerns about what's going on with the branch.
我会在药店买一株植物。结账处旁边有那些植物。我会买一盆。她已经尽力了。她试图给前台带来一些欢快的气氛。好吧，我们有迈克尔和简通电话的场景。她试图解释她对分公司发生的事情的担忧。
But he just invites her to Casino Night. And she's like, Michael, I'm concerned for the branch. And he wants to have this elaborate party that costs so much money. Yeah. And she's just like, Michael, I'm not coming to that. But maybe later. It's something else.
但他只是邀请她去赌场之夜。她就像，迈克尔，我在为分公司担心。而他却想举办这个花费巨大的精心派对。是的。而她只是说，迈克尔，我不去那儿。但也许以后吧。还有别的事。
OK, so next up, at four minutes, 11 seconds, Michael's in the bullpen. He's sitting on Pam's desk. He's explaining that we're having Casino Night, that the beneficiary is Boy Scouts of America, and that the big winner of the night is going to get $500 to donate to the charity of their choice and a mini-fridge compliments of Vance Refrigeration.
好的，接下来，在四分11秒，迈克尔在办公区。他坐在帕姆的桌子上。他解释说我们要举办赌场之夜，受益者是美国童子军，当晚的大赢家将获得500美元捐给他们选择的慈善机构，以及由万斯制冷赞助的小型冰箱。
Yes, to which Phyllis is so proud. Oh my gosh. So proud. If you freeze at four minutes, 34 seconds, Phyllis' face, she actually sticks her tongue out. She's like, what? She's so happy that Vance Refrigeration is donating the prize. But before we get there, I have to point out
是的，对此菲利斯感到非常自豪。哦，天哪。太骄傲了。如果你在四分34秒暂停，菲利斯的脸，她实际上吐出了舌头。她就像，什么？她太高兴万斯制冷赞助这个奖品了。但在我们到那儿之前，我必须指出
a great screen grab. At four minutes, 14 seconds, for those of you guys that have been tuning in, I talk about what I call the accountant stack. It's how they stack the accounting department to get them in the bullpen, because we're tucked around the corner. So you wouldn't see us.
一个很棒的截屏。在四分14秒，对于那些一直在收看的观众，我谈到了我称之为会计堆栈的东西。这是他们如何将会计部门堆叠起来让他们进入办公区，因为我们被藏在角落里。所以你看不到我们。
So they would pull us out in this formation. And it's the best screen grab of it I have seen yet. It is me at the copier with Oscar just like two feet behind me and then Brian like three feet behind Oscar. It is like, literally, we look like a row of dominoes. And it's so we could be in the scene and react. That is perfect. I remember that they would do that.
所以他们会以这种队形把我们拉出来。这是我见过的最好的截屏之一。是我在复印机旁，奥斯卡就在我身后大约两英尺，然后布莱恩在奥斯卡身后大约三英尺。这就像，字面意思，我们看起来像一排多米诺骨牌。这正是为了让我们能在场景中并做出反应。太完美了。我记得他们会那样做。
And sometimes it would make no sense that everyone else was able to sit at their desks and listen to Michael, but you guys would have to get up and walk over a little bit and stand during the whole time. Yes, I would be so envious of people that got to sit through really long scenes, because we'd just be standing by the copier.
有时这毫无意义，其他人都能坐在桌子旁听迈克尔说话，而你们却不得不站起来走过去一点，在整个过程中一直站着。是的，我会非常嫉妒那些能坐着听完整场长戏的人，因为我们只能站在复印机旁。
Oh, that's a good thing when you're rewatching these episodes for people to just know how often the accountants are standing up. Yeah, while everyone else is sitting. So then we lead into this series of talking heads where everyone explains where they would donate the money, should they be the big winner for the night. And you know, Creed has a talking head
哦，当人们重温这些剧集时，知道会计们站着有多么频繁，这是一件好事。是的，而其他人都在坐着。然后我们进入了一系列采访，每个人都解释了如果他们成为当晚的大赢家，他们会将钱捐到哪里。你知道，奎德有一个采访
where he says he's going to give the money to a soup kitchen. Yeah, that has a really delicious pea soup on Thursdays. Creed, Kevin says to animals or people, once again, reminding us that he is maybe not the smartest. Angela, you have a great talking head. So much sass. I am not wanting to participate in this casino night. I say that we're just going to be giving money.
在那里他说他要把钱捐给一家流浪汉收容所。是的，周四有非常美味的豌豆汤。奎德，凯文对动物还是人，再次提醒我们他可能不是最聪明的。安吉拉，你有一个很棒的采访。充满了傲慢。我不想参加这个赌场之夜。我说我们只是在送钱。
That's from gambling. Why don't we just deal drugs or prostitute ourselves? Yeah, just give that money to charity. I know. I'm sure she's A, not happy because she's not getting to plan this party. B, it's gambling and there's alcohol. But Jenna, she shows up.
那是通过赌博得来的。我们为什么不直接贩毒或卖淫呢？是的，把那些钱捐给慈善机构吧。我知道。我敢肯定她，A，不高兴，因为她没有得到策划这个派对的机会。B，那是赌博，还有酒精。但珍娜，她出现了。
Well, she's going to show up later to this casino night. Yeah, she does. So this leads into one of my favorite scenes with some of my favorite lines of all time ever from the series, ever. I know what you're saying. I know what you're going to talk about. Michael announces that at the end of the night,
好吧，她稍后会出现在这个赌场之夜。是的，她会的。所以这引出了我最喜欢的场景之一，里面有我一直以来最喜欢的一些台词，永远。我知道你在说什么。我知道你要谈论什么。迈克尔宣布，在当晚结束时，
they're going to present a giant check to some Boy Scouts. He's so excited. That's so him, right? He's so delighted that they're going to have a giant check. And Toby's like, oh, actually, Michael, that's not true. And then he lists the many reasons why it would be inappropriate to have kids come to a casino night.
他们将向一些童子军颁发一张巨型支票。他太兴奋了。这太符合他的作风了，对吧？他太高兴他们能有一张巨型支票了。托比说，哦，其实，迈克尔，那不是真的。然后他列举了许多不适合让孩子们来参加赌场之夜的理由。
He's like gambling, alcohol. It's in a dangerous warehouse. It's a school night. Hooters is catering. Do I need to say more? Yeah, do I need to go on? So this leads to the classic Michael line. Why are you the way that you are?
他说赌博、酒精。这是一个危险的仓库。这是一个上学之夜。由猫头鹰餐厅提供餐饮。我需要多说吗？是的，我需要继续说吗？所以这引出了经典的迈克尔台词。你为什么是现在这样的人？
Michael Sass, I wrote. Michael Sass. Michael Sass. This next line is my most absolute favorite, Angela. I hate so much about the things that you choose to be. I could not get through that. So that whole thing that Michael says like that, why are you the way that you are, all of that was scripted.
迈克尔的傲慢，我写下了。迈克尔的傲慢。迈克尔的傲慢。接下来这句台词是我绝对最喜欢的，安吉拉。我太讨厌你选择成为的那种人了。我简直无法撑过去。所以迈克尔说的所有那些话，你为什么是现在这样的人，所有这些都是剧本里写好的。
It's in the script word for word. So good. Then Michael announces that he is going to donate to Afghanistanis with AIDS. Well, we got a fan question from Augusta. She said, one of my absolute favorite scenes of all time is the Afghan-Afghanistanis scene. Was any of that improvised or was that all scripted?
剧本里一字不差。太棒了。然后迈克尔宣布他要捐给患有艾滋病的阿富汗人。好吧，我们收到了奥古斯塔的粉丝提问。她说，我一直以来最喜欢的场景之一就是阿富汗-阿富汗人场景。这里面有即兴发挥的吗，还是全都是剧本写好的？
All right, I went to the script and it's mostly all scripted with the exception of one line, which is John Krasinski. He improvised Afghanistanis. He was supposed to just say Afghanistanis. Way to go, John. Way to go. That was a good one. Way to put a button on it.
好吧，我查了剧本，除了约翰·卡拉辛斯基的一句台词外，几乎全都是剧本写好的。他即兴发挥了阿富汗人。他本应该只说阿富汗人。干得好，约翰。干得好。那是一个不错的。给它画上了一个完美的句号。
Way to put a button on it. Jenna, I need to talk to you about what happens at 7 minutes 31 seconds. Oh, yeah. Because Jim offers to watch crappy wedding bands with Pam. And she's so happy. Oh, my gosh. She's so happy.
给它画上了一个完美的句号。珍娜，我需要和你谈谈在7分31秒发生的事。哦，是的。因为吉姆主动提出和帕姆一起看糟糕的婚礼乐队。她太高兴了。哦，天哪。她太高兴了。
Well, she should be doing this with Roy. I mean, she says Roy was going to pick the band, but now he's too busy planning his bachelor party. I mean, how many red flags does someone need? She's planning her wedding with the guy she's in love with that's not her fiance. Yeah. And then Jim has the line that breaks your heart.
好吧，她本该和罗伊一起做这事的。我的意思是，她说罗伊本打算挑选乐队，但他现在太忙于策划单身派对。我的意思是，一个人需要多少红旗？她在和她深爱但不是她未婚妻的男人策划婚礼。是的。然后吉姆说了一句让你心碎的话。
At 8 minutes, he says, I mean, I talked to Jan about a transfer because I have no future here. Yeah. He has no future there. I know. I know. So now they go, you know, we're jumping around a little, but let's see this Jim Pam moment through.
在8分钟的时候，他说，我的意思是，我和简谈过调动的事，因为我在那里没有未来。是的。他在那里没有未来。我知道。我知道。所以现在他们去了，你知道的，我们跳来跳去了一点，但让我们看完这个吉姆和帕姆的时刻。
OK, lady. All right. They're in the conference room. They're watching these band videos. By the way, we got a ton of questions about Brian's drumming. So many people wrote in. Yes. So they put in a tape and they realized, oh, my gosh.
好的，女士。好的。他们在会议室里。他们在看这些乐队视频。顺便说一句，我们收到了大量关于布莱恩打鼓的问题。很多人写信来。是的。所以他们放了一卷磁带，然后他们意识到，哦，天哪。
That's Kevin. Yeah. Kevin is in a band. Guess who came up with the band name Scrantonicity? Who? Mindy. Really? That was Mindy.
那是凯文。是的。凯文在一个乐队里。你猜是谁想出了“Scrantonicity”这个乐队名字的？谁？明迪。真的吗？那是明迪。
That was Mindy. That's that was her idea, that name. Well, check this out. When I looked at this scene in the script, the name of the band is not Scrantonicity. Oh, yeah. What was it? Jokers and Tokers.
那是明迪。那是她的主意，那个名字。好吧，看看这个。当我看到剧本里的这个场景时，乐队的名字不是“Scrantonicity”。哦，真的是什么？小丑和瘾君子。
So I texted Brian because we got a lot of questions about is he really drumming? Is he really singing? Yeah. And I also had to get to the bottom of this jokers and Tokers business. Brian told me that he is actually playing and singing a Steve Miller song in the video.
所以我给布莱恩发了短信，因为我们收到了很多关于他是否真的在打鼓的问题。他真的是在唱歌吗？是的。我还不得不弄清楚这个小丑和瘾君子的事情。布莱恩告诉我，他在视频中实际上是在演奏和演唱一首史蒂夫·米勒的歌。
And I mean, he says he's playing, but he's really kind of faking it because he didn't really learn to drum until later when his band had to play. Was it at Phyllis's wedding? Yeah. He had to be on stage, right? Yeah.
我的意思是，他说他在弹奏，但他实际上有点在假装，因为他直到后来他的乐队必须演出时才真正学会打鼓。是在菲利斯的婚礼上吗？是的。他不得不上台，对吧？是的。
So he's kind of faking his way through the song. So after they shot this whole scene of him and his band, they could not get permission from Steve Miller to use the song. So in post, they turned it into a police tribute band. And that's when they changed the name to Scrantonicity. And Brian had to dub his voice singing Don't Stand So Close To Me.
所以他有点在蒙混过关。所以在他们拍摄了他和他的乐队的整个场景后，他们无法获得史蒂夫·米勒使用这首歌的许可。所以在后期制作中，他们把它变成了一个警察致敬乐队。这就是他们把名字改成“Scrantonicity”的时候。布莱恩不得不为自己唱的《不要靠我太近》配音。
And that's what they ended up playing. So if you watch that video, the lyrics do not match his mouth. I didn't notice it until after Brian told me all this stuff, though. Oh, that's good. And I caught a couple of other little tidbits based on this knowledge. Notice that at 9 minutes 43 seconds,
这就是他们最后播放的。所以如果你看那个视频，歌词和他的嘴型对不上。不过，直到布莱恩告诉我所有这些事情之前，我都没有注意到。哦，那挺好的。基于这些知识，我还捕捉到了其他一些小花絮。注意，在9分43秒，
there's a close-up of John's hand putting the tape into the tape player. And it says Scrantonicity. I remember shooting that later. I remember having to do a pickup of John's hand putting in Scrantonicity. OK. And then later in the warehouse,
有一个约翰的手把磁带放进磁带播放器的特写镜头。上面写着“Scrantonicity”。我记得后来拍摄了那个。我记得不得不补拍约翰的手把“Scrantonicity”放进去的镜头。好的。然后后来在仓库里，
Roy is going to come up to Kevin and he's going to say, hey, I heard about your band Scrantonicity, right? This happens at 22 minutes and five seconds. Yeah. The band name is said off camera. It's Roy's voice, but on camera is Kevin. And they had to dub that, too. That was some good behind-the-scenes tidbits
罗伊会走向凯文，他会说，嘿，我听说过你的乐队“Scrantonicity”，对吧？这发生在22分5秒。是的。乐队名字是在画外音里说的。那是罗伊的声音，但镜头上是凯文。他们也必须为那个配音。这是一些很好的幕后花絮
for Scrantonicity, lady. I know. Thank you, Brian Baumgartner. OK, so we're jumping around a bit, but back at 8 minutes 16 seconds, we have Daryl and Michael's office. He's like, look, I'm not having fire eaters in a paper warehouse. So why does he want fire eaters at a casino night anyway?
关于“Scrantonicity”的，女士。我知道。谢谢你，布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳。好的，所以我们跳来跳去了一点，但在8分16秒，我们来到了达瑞尔和迈克尔的办公室。他说，听着，我不在造纸仓库里搞吞火表演。那他为什么还要在赌场之夜安排吞火表演呢？
Let me tell you, he would have a full circus in there if he could. He wants it bigger, louder, crazier. And then Dwight enters for, quote, protection. And then there's this very funny exchange where we learn that Daryl has taught phrases to Michael to help him with his interracial conversations. We learn about Dink and Flicka, Dink and Flicka, this handshake.
让我告诉你，如果他可以的话，他会在里面办一个完整的马戏团。他想让它更大、更吵、更疯狂。然后德怀特为了所谓的“保护”走了进来。然后有一段非常有趣的对话，我们了解到达瑞尔教给迈克尔一些短语来帮助他进行跨种族对话。我们了解到了Dink和Flicka，Dink和Flicka，这个握手动作。
And Daryl has a great talking head. And Jenna, I'm pretty sure that this is Craig Robinson's very first talking head, I think, in this episode. I think it is. Well, Angela, I looked up Dink and Flicka on Urban Dictionary. You did? Does it reference the office? Yes.
达瑞尔有一个很棒的采访，珍娜，我很确定这是克雷格·罗宾逊在这集里的第一个采访，我想。我想是的。好吧，安吉拉，我在城市词典上查了Dink和Flicka。你查了？它提到了《办公室》吗？是的。
It says, made popular in a recent episode of The Office, Dink and Flicka roughly translates to That's Life, or Say Love Thee. I sort of remember that as talking about that, Dink and Flicka, and that Steve had just made it up. I don't know if I'm remembering that long, but I think that is just out of Steve Carell's mind. Also, Fleece It Out, that was another one.
上面说，因在最近一集的《办公室》中走红，Dink和Flicka大致翻译为“这就是生活”或“向你问好”。我有点记得讨论过这个，Dink和Flicka，那是史蒂夫凭空捏造出来的。我不知道我记的时间是不是太久了，但我认为那只是出自史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的脑海。还有，Fleece It Out，那是另一个。
That's also in the Urban Dictionary. I kind of love that these two made up phrases are now in the Urban Dictionary as sort of fictional phrases. Way to go, Steve Carell. Way to go, Steve Carell. Well, there is some delicious pamsass coming up. Oh, yes. OK.
那也在城市词典里。我有点喜欢这两个编造出来的短语现在作为虚构短语出现在城市词典里。干得好，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。干得好，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。好吧，接下来有一些精彩的帕姆傲慢片段。哦，是的。好的。
All right. I love this bit so much. This is one of the things our show did that I love, where we find out information that something a character has been doing for years, but we didn't know it. And this is one of those moments. So at 10 minutes, 58 seconds, Carol stills calls. Pam's like, Michael, Carol's on the phone.
好吧。我太喜欢这个桥段了。这是我们节目做的我最喜欢的事情之一，我们发现了一些信息，关于一个角色多年来一直在做但我们却不知道的事情。这就是其中一个时刻。所以在10分58秒，卡萝尔·斯蒂尔斯打电话来。帕姆说，迈克尔，卡萝尔在打电话。
And she does this thing where she doesn't let it through right away. She's like, still me, still me. Yes, because she has to. She says Michael is better at the second attempt. He's better at his second pass with people. Because the first time, he says some ridiculous thing. Did you have it written down? What does he say to Carol the first time?
她做了一件她没有马上把电话转过去的事。她说，还是我，还是我。是的，因为她必须这样做。她说迈克尔在第二次尝试时表现得更好。他在与人接触的第二轮中表现得更好。因为第一次，他说了一些荒谬的话。你把它写下来了吗？他对卡萝尔第一次说了什么？
He says, hey, Carol, how's the real estate biz? Is it real good? And Pam's like, still me. And then the second time, he's totally normal. Yeah, he's like, hey, Carol, what's up? It's so good. And then the same thing happens. This is a great scene.
他说，嘿，卡萝尔，房地产业务怎么样？真的很好吗？然后帕姆说，还是我。然后第二次，他完全正常了。是的，他就像，嘿，卡萝尔，怎么了？太棒了。然后同样的事情发生了。这是一个很棒的场景。
So Michael's on the phone with Carol. And she just needs one last signature for his mortgage insurance. That's why she's calling. But he tells Carol, you should come to Casino Night. And she's like, yeah, to get the signature? Or it's a little confusing what he's asking, right? And Nancy did such a great job with that.
所以迈克尔在和卡萝尔通电话。她只需要他房屋贷款保险的最后一份签名。这就是她打电话的原因。但他告诉卡萝尔，你应该来赌场之夜。而她就像，是的，去拿签名？或者他问的问题有点让人糊涂，对吧？南希把那段演得太棒了。
I've just been like, wait, to your party? That's where I get the signature? Yes. We should remind people, guys, Carol Stills, played by Nancy Carell, Steve's wife in real life. So then the other line, Pam's putting through another call. It's Jan. And uh-oh, Jan is calling to tell Michael, Michael,
我当时就像，等等，去你的派对？我在那里拿签名？是的。我们应该提醒大家，伙计们，卡萝尔·斯蒂尔斯，由南希·卡瑞尔饰演，也就是史蒂夫现实生活中的妻子。然后另一条线，帕姆正在转接另一个电话。是简。哦，不，简打电话来告诉迈克尔，迈克尔，
I would love to come to Casino Night. I feel like you can watch Steve as Michael literally break into a sweat. He's like, holy crap. When in a million years did I think that I'd have two women on the line who'd both just said yes to me within seconds of each other? Two queens on Casino Night.
我很想去赌场之夜。我觉得你可以看到史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔字面意义上急出了汗。他就像，天哪。我怎么会在几百万年里想到我有两个女人在电话线上，她们都在几秒钟内对我说“好”？赌场之夜的两个女王。
Gonna have to drop a noose. Oh, boy. So that's a big cliffhanger. We go into what would normally be a commercial break right there. Should we go into a break? Let's go into a break, because now we're going to get into the casino game.
得挂一个了。哦，天哪。所以这是一个巨大的悬念。我们进入了通常应该是广告时间的地方。我们应该去休息一下吗？我们去休息一下吧，因为现在我们要进入赌场游戏了。
And a lot, a lot is going to happen. All right, we are back. And we are at the casino. The casino is open. Gambling is happening. It's open for bidness. At 13 minutes, 22 seconds. It is happening, Jenna.
会有很多很多事情发生。好的，我们回来了。我们到了赌场。赌场开业了。赌博正在进行中。开张大吉。在13分22秒。开始了，珍娜。
You are wearing quite the dress. Oh, actually, I've got very dressed up for this. We got a ton of mail about your dress. Matt Mabe said, how many different dresses did you try on before you settled on the blue one that you wore? Danny Thurgood said, my wife has a theory that the dress Pam wears was an old bridesmaid's dress
你穿着相当漂亮的裙子。哦，实际上，我为此盛装打扮了。我们收到了大量关于你裙子的信件。马特·梅布说，在你决定穿这件蓝色的之前，你试穿了多少件不同的裙子？丹尼·瑟古德说，我妻子有一个理论，说帕姆穿的裙子是旧伴娘裙
that Pam had in her closet. Danny, I wrote on a note card, Pam in a bridesmaid's dress? Question mark. It really looks like a bridesmaid's dress. It really does. Yes. And then original Gus girl said, whose decision was it for Pam to wear her watch with her gown?
帕姆放在她的衣橱里。丹尼，我在便签纸上写下，帕姆穿着伴娘裙？问号。它看起来真的很像一件伴娘裙。确实很像。是的。然后原版加斯女孩说，谁决定让帕姆穿着她的手表配礼服的？
It was a subtle but great costuming and character choice. I love all of these questions. You guys are so observant. All right, let me start by saying Angela and Danny's wife, you guys are correct. Was it a bridesmaid's dress? Well, that was the inspiration. When I met with Carrie, our wardrobe designer,
这是一个微妙但出色的服装和角色选择。我喜欢所有这些问题。你们太善于观察了。好吧，首先我要说，安吉拉和丹尼的妻子，你们猜对了。这是一件伴娘裙吗？好吧，这就是灵感来源。当我与我们的服装设计师凯莉会面时，
about this outfit that Pam would wear, we said, you know what? We want her to be dressed up in like a cocktail dress. But on Pam's salary and just thinking about Pam's life, when would she ever buy a cocktail dress? And she's certainly not going to buy one just for Casino Night. So we had a whole conversation where we were like, you know what?
关于帕姆要穿的这套衣服，我们说，你知道吗？我们希望她穿得像鸡尾酒裙一样得体。但在帕姆的薪水和对帕姆生活的考虑下，她什么时候会买一件鸡尾酒裙？她肯定不会仅仅为了赌场之夜去买一件。所以我们进行了一场谈话，我们觉得，你知道吗？
I think she rewears an old bridesmaid's dress. That's the fanciest thing she has in her closet. And that's what she wears. I'll have you know. That was the first dress I tried on. We loved it. She had a whole rack of dresses, and I tried them all on. That was our favorite.
我觉得她重复穿了一件旧伴娘裙。那是她衣橱里最华丽的东西。这就是她穿的。我得告诉你。那是我试穿的第一条裙子。我们很喜欢。她有一整排裙子，我都试穿了。那是我们最喜欢的。
And we sent that picture to Greg, and he approved it immediately. It was like a winner from the start. Well, that is so great and perfect, and really answers my burning question. So I was like, I feel like I wore a bridesmaid's dress that looks similar to that to a wedding in the 90s. By the way, I love that watch question, Angela,
我们把那张照片发给了格雷格，他立刻批准了。就像一开局就赢了一样。好吧，这太棒了，太完美了，真正解答了我迫切的问题。所以我就像，我觉得我在90年代参加婚礼时穿过一件看起来和那个差不多的伴娘裙。顺便说一句，我喜欢那个关于手表的问题，安吉拉，
because that was a discussion. It was a discussion that Pam wears that watch every day. Most of the time, you can't see it, but every day, Phil Shea would come up to me and he had a little tray, and it had my watch, and it had my Pam wedding ring on it, or my Pam engagement ring on it. And you pick it up, you put it on first thing in the morning,
因为那是一次讨论。那是关于帕姆每天都戴着那块手表的讨论。大多数时候，你看不见它，但每天，菲尔·谢伊都会走到我面前，他拿着一个小盘子，上面有我的手表，还有我的帕姆结婚戒指，或者我的帕姆订婚戒指。你把它拿起来，一大早戴上，
take it off at the end of the night. And so I've always been wearing that watch, but you cannot normally see it because it's underneath my sleeve, right? So we had a whole discussion. Does Pam wear her watch with her fancy dress or not? And we thought, listen, guys, this is back before iPhones. You didn't have the time in your back pocket
在一天结束时把它摘下来。所以我一直戴着那块手表，但你通常看不到它，因为它在我的袖子下面，对吧？所以我们进行了整个讨论。帕姆应该戴着手表配她的华丽礼服还是不戴？我们想，听着，伙计们，这是在iPhone出现之前。你的后口袋里没有时间
the way you do now. And we discussed that Pam does not have a fancy watch. So she's got one watch and she wore it. And I can't believe someone noticed that detail. Thanks for noticing. Pam would wear her watch. That made such sense to me. I love it.
像你现在这样。我们讨论过帕姆没有那种昂贵的表。所以她只有一块表，而且她戴着它。我简直不敢相信有人注意到了这个细节。谢谢你注意到。帕姆会戴着她的表。这让我觉得太合情合理了。我很喜欢。
I feel like she also probably has a pair of Keds on standby that she can change into. I love that. Angela, what about your dress? You're wearing a black dress, which is in your color scheme, but I mean, it's a little bit, it's a bit, what? Sultry, it's somewhat tight.
我觉得她大概还备着一双Keds运动鞋，可以随时换上。我太喜欢了。安吉拉，你的裙子呢？你穿了一件黑裙子，这很符合你的穿衣风格，不过我的意思是，这有点，这有点，什么？性感迷人，还有点紧身。
It's an LBD for sure. It is a little black dress. I mean, I have a little bit of cleavage. Yeah. A little bit. A little bit. It is a tight little black dress. I feel like she probably wore it to a funeral and maybe it had some lace attachment over her decotage.
这绝对是一条LBD（小黑裙）。它就是一条小黑裙。我的意思是，我有一点事业线。对。一点点。一点点。它是一条紧身的小黑裙。我觉得她可能是穿着它去参加葬礼，也许她的胸前还配有一些蕾丝。
But maybe she's feeling a little saucy. So she was like, I'm not gonna wear this sweater that goes with it. I do have a sweater that comes in and out of scenes. I don't know. If you notice right at the top, I'm holding it. And then later on, you see me wearing it. But yeah, I know I'm wearing a little black dress.
但也许她现在感觉有点俏皮。所以她就想，我才不穿这件与之配套的毛衣呢。我的确有一件在镜头里时隐时现的毛衣。不知道。如果你注意到最开始的时候，我正拿着它。然后过一会儿，你就会看到我穿着它。不过，是的，我知道我穿着一条小黑裙。
I have to point out, it's jumping around, but I have a great catch of someone breaking character. Oh. And that someone is me. At 13 minutes, 24 seconds, there is a shot of Angela Martin talking to Meredith. And you see at the very beginning of the moment,
我必须指出，虽然有点跳跃，但我抓拍到了一个演员出戏的精彩瞬间。哦。而那个人就是我。在13分24秒时，有一个安吉拉·马丁和梅雷迪思交谈的镜头。你会发现在这个瞬间的最开始，
maybe I'm aware that camera's panning over and so I have a solemn look. And then clearly I think camera has gone off of us. And then I just go, I just like start gesturing. And I think I can make out the words I have to pee or something. Oh my gosh, what else is going on? Are you in the background of another scene?
也许我知道镜头正摇过来，所以我摆出了一副严肃的表情。然后很明显我觉得镜头已经移开我们了。接着我就，我就开始手舞足蹈地比划起来。我想我当时能看出自己在说“我要去洗手间”或者类似的话。哦天哪，还有什么别的花絮？你在另一个场景的背景里吗？
I'm in the background of an establishing shot of you and Roy gambling. And then it pans over to the rest of us. Jim's at another table. I'm talking to Meredith. I'm holding my sweater. And at the very beginning of it, I have a solemn face. And then within seconds, I think the camera's gone.
我是你和罗伊赌博的一个建立镜头的背景。然后镜头摇向了我们其他人。吉姆在另一张桌子旁。我在跟梅雷迪思说话。我拿着我的毛衣。而在这一切的最开始，我是一张严肃的脸。然后几秒钟内，我觉得镜头已经切走了，
I just start being chatty. It's 100% me just talking. Oh my gosh. All right, should we get into it now? Let's get into it. Create a stealing poker chips. Carol has arrived. Dwight is Michael's wingman, I guess.
我就开始闲聊起来。百分之百是我自己在说话。哦天哪。好了，我们现在要进入正题了吗？我们开始吧。卡罗尔偷筹码。卡罗尔到了。德怀特是迈克尔的僚机，我猜是的。
And Toby just beat Michael at cards. Yes. And I have a few fan questions about that stuff. The first one comes from Jessica Merkner. She says, Dwight is a terrible wingman. His inability to warn Michael that Jan is coming is great. Was any of that improvised? All right, so I looked at the script.
托比刚刚在牌桌上赢了迈克尔。是的。我有一些关于这方面的粉丝提问。第一个问题来自杰西卡·梅克纳。她说，德怀特是个糟糕的僚机。他没能提醒迈克尔说简要来了，这太绝了。这里面有任何即兴发挥吗？好了，所以我查了一下剧本。
And you know when Carol first arrives and Dwight comes up and says, code remax is here, but no sign of Land Jevenson. Yeah. It's so good. That second part was improvised. So I'm not sure. That's so good.
你知道卡罗尔刚到时，德怀特走过来宣布，雷马克代码已就位，但不见伦杰文森的踪影吗？是的。太棒了。第二部分是即兴发挥的。所以我不太确定。这太棒了。
I know. I'm not sure if Rain did it or if it was like one of the writer pitches on set, because we would have writers on set that would pitch us jokes. But the original line was supposed to be no sign of date number two, which is also very funny because it is in no way coded. And also out loud, he says, Michael has a second date.
我知道。我不确定这是雷恩自己想的，还是片场某个编剧提议的，因为我们片场会有编剧给我们提笑话。但原本的台词应该是“不见第二个约会对象的踪影”，这其实也很好笑，因为它一点都不像暗号。而且他还大声说出来，说迈克尔有了第二个约会对象。
All right, so Jenna, at 18 minutes, 26 seconds, I have a card called Kiss Slap some Merk. Oh, this is a classic. This is a classic Dwight Angela moment. It's when Dwight is playing crafts and Angela walks up in her little black dress. And she's like, what are you doing? And they're very formal with one another, you know?
好了，詹娜，在18分26秒，我有一段叫作“亲吻耳光塞姆·默克”的桥段。哦，这是个经典。这是德怀特和安吉拉的经典时刻。当时德怀特在玩双骰子游戏，安吉拉穿着她的小黑裙走了过来。然后她问，你在干什么？他们彼此之间非常正式，你知道吗？
Very formal. And he's like, Angela, I need to roll an eight. And everyone wins. And she says, so roll an eight. And then he does. Yes. And he is so excited that he grabs you and he kisses you on the cheek.
非常正式。然后他说，安吉拉，我需要掷出一个八。大家就都赢了。她就说，那就掷出一个八。然后他就照做了。是的。他激动得一把抓住你，还在你的脸颊上亲了一下。
I know. And listen, even though maybe she's happy about that, she has to slap him for being inappropriate at work. Yes. Well, Angela, we got a fan question from Heather Lindo. Sam, will you play it? Hi, Jenna. Hi, Angela.
我知道。听着，尽管她可能对此很高兴，但她不得不因为他在工作场合行为不当而扇他一巴掌。是的。好吧，安吉拉，我们收到了海瑟·林多的粉丝提问。山姆，你能放一下吗？嗨，詹娜。嗨，安吉拉。
Casino Night is one of my very favorite episodes for a lot of reasons. And one of them being the scene at the craps table when Dwight kisses Angela for good luck. And then she slaps him. But when she turns around, her face is just perfection. She cycles through like 10 emotions in a matter of like three seconds.
赌场之夜是我最喜欢的剧集之一，原因有很多。其中之一就是双骰子赌桌旁的那个场景，德怀特为了求好运亲了安吉拉。然后她扇了他一巴掌。但当她转过身时，她的表情简直完美。她在短短大约三秒钟内转换了大约10种情绪。
She is horrified and thrilled and embarrassed and obviously deep down very happy all at the same time. And I just love it. And Angela, my question is, did you nail that on the first take or did you have to do it many, many times? Thank you so much for letting me ask my question. I know everyone says this, but my sister Kim and I really are the Office number one fans.
她既震惊、狂喜、尴尬，显然内心深处又非常高兴，所有这一切同时发生。我太喜欢了。安吉拉，我的问题是，你是一条过就拍成了，还是拍了很多很多次？非常感谢你们让我有机会提问。我知道每个人都这么说，但我姐姐金和我真的是《办公室》的头号粉丝。
We just love you so much. So thank you. Oh my God, Heather. That was so sweet. I love that question so much. OK, so I was very excited about this question because I actually wrote in my journal about this scene. Of course you did.
我们太爱你们了。所以非常感谢。哦天哪，海瑟。这太甜了。我太喜欢这个问题了。好吧，我之所以对这个问题感到非常兴奋，是因为我实际上在我的日记里写下了关于这个场景的内容。你当然写了。
Of course we did. I wrote about it the week we filmed it. To answer your question, Heather, no, I did not get it right the first time. OK, so I wrote that I was really nervous to slap Rain. At first, you know, my slap was kind of timid, which makes sense because you were probably very, you were worried about hurting him.
我们当然写了。我在我们拍摄它的那周就写了。回答你的问题，海瑟，不，我不是一次就拍成功的。好吧，我写道，我当时其实很紧张要扇雷恩耳光。起码你知道的，我的巴掌有点畏缩，这很合情合理，因为你当时可能非常，你担心会弄伤他。
Exactly. I don't want to hurt him. And it wasn't a fake slap. They told you to really slap him. That was they never did a phony slap. No, they wanted a real slap. And well, I guess my timid little slap wasn't working. So Rain said, listen, Ange, just go for it.
没错。我不想弄伤他。而且这不是假打。他们要求你真打。他们从来没拍过假打。不，他们想要真的耳光。而且，嗯，我猜我那怯生生的小巴掌不管用。所以雷恩说，听着，安吉拉，直接上吧。我扛得住。所以我开始动真格地扇他了。
I can take it. So I started really slapping him. Oh, no. And I wrote that it took us about 13 takes to get. Oh, no. Yes. So that's 13 slaps. All right, here's the one thing I need you guys to remember.
哦，不。我写道，我们拍了大约13条才过。哦，不。是的。也就是说挨了13个巴掌。好了，这里有件事我需要你们记住。
I am 5'1". Rain is like 6'3". So it wasn't really easy for me to reach his cheek. And one time, my aim was really off. And I missed his cheek. And I slapped his ear so hard. He was like, it actually hurt him. He said there was like a ringing in his ear.
我身高1米55。雷恩身高大概1米9。所以要够到他的脸颊真不是件容易的事。有一次，我瞄得实在太偏了。我没打中他的脸颊。我狠狠地扇在了他的耳朵上。他当时说，这真的弄疼他了。他说他的耳朵里一直在嗡嗡作响。
And then the other time I missed. And I slapped and I hit his glasses. And I knocked them sideways on his face. I know, I know. Well, I want to go back to something that Heather said too about that look on your face as you're walking away. Because it is amazing.
还有一次我打偏了。我一巴掌挥过去，打到了他的眼镜。把眼镜在他脸上扇歪了。我懂，我懂。好吧，我还想回到海瑟刚才提到的关于你转身离开时脸上表情的那件事上。因为那太棒了。
And I have the script and I looked it up. And all it says is that you slapped Dwight and that you smile as you walk away from the table. I think there's so much more going on in your face. So your character is angry that Dwight would kiss you so publicly and all of that. But what I love is that you have this little look to the camera at the very end.
我手里有剧本，我查过了。上面只写着你扇了德怀特一巴掌，然后微笑着离开赌桌。我觉得你脸上的戏要丰富得多。所以你的角色很生气，因为德怀特居然当着那么多人的面亲你，诸如此类。但让我最喜欢的是，你在最后有一个冲镜头挑眉的微表情。
It's like 18 minutes, 48 seconds. Yeah. Where you sort of catch the camera catching you smiling. That camera catch was not in the script. Was that improvised? Yes, it was. OK, so that just happened on the day. That little moment where I busted at the end.
大概在18分48秒。是的。你好像刚好被镜头捕捉到了你的微笑。那个镜头捕捉并不在剧本里。那是即兴发挥吗？是的，是的。好吧，那是现场碰巧发生的。最后我笑场的那一小会儿。
So in one of the early takes, I was walking out of frame and I just looked at camera and I quickly looked away. Like I was embarrassed that they caught me smiling. And our director of photography, Randall Einhorn, said, Ang, I caught it right at the end as you're leaving frame. And he really helped me find that moment. Then he showed it to our director. Our director loved it.
所以在其中一个早期的镜头里，我正走出画幅，我只是看了一眼镜头，然后又迅速移开视线。就像是因为他们抓拍到我笑而感到尴尬一样。我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾因霍恩说，安吉拉，我在你离开画幅的最后那一刻捕捉到了。他真的帮我找到了那个时刻。然后他把这个拿给我们的导演看。我们的导演非常喜欢。
And so Randall was like, Ang, you don't have a lot of time to cycle through all that. But I'm going to catch it every time if you've glanced the camera and quickly look away embarrassed. So I have to thank Randall for that because he really helped me make that moment happen. I love that. Yes.
所以兰德尔就说，安吉拉，你没有太多时间去把那些情绪全演一遍，但如果你快速瞥一眼镜头然后又不好意思地移开，我每次都能抓拍到。所以我必须感谢兰德尔，因为他真的帮我促成了那一刻。我太喜欢了。是的。
All right, folks out there that love background catches. I have one more moment for you in this little scene. At 18 minutes, 51 seconds, you can really see how red the side of rain spaces. And it's because I have slapped him 13 times. Well, there you have it, Heather. Thank you for such a great question. Thank you, Heather.
好了，各位喜欢看背景花絮的朋友们。我在这场小戏里还有一个瞬间要分享给你们。在18分51秒，你们真的能看清雷恩脸的一侧有多红。那是因为我扇了他13次耳光。好吧，就是这样，海瑟。谢谢你提出这么棒的问题。谢谢你，海瑟。
I love that question. OK, so Angela, you just described the big kind of Dwight Angela flirt moment that happens in front of everybody at the casino night. So now we head over to the poker table where it is heads up between Jim and Pam. And I feel like this is the big Jim Pam flirt moment that's public.
我太喜欢这个提问了。好吧，安吉拉，你刚刚描述了在赌场之夜所有人面前发生的大型德怀特和安吉拉调情时刻。现在我们转向扑克牌桌，那是吉姆和帕姆之间的对决。我觉得这是公开的大型吉姆和帕姆调情时刻。
There is so much flirting happening. Pam is basically doing the giggle hair toss move from about last night. I mean, it is on. It is on. Well, we had a fan question from Live Love, California. The scene at the poker table when you and John are making those faces back and forth,
有太多的调情正在发生了。帕姆基本上在重现昨晚那种咯咯笑、甩头发的动作。我的意思是，开始了。真的开始了。好吧，我们收到了来自加州“爱生活”的粉丝提问。扑克桌上你和约翰眉来眼去的那个场景，
was that improvised or scripted? This is what was scripted. Those little looks between us. There was a scene description, and so what you're seeing is John and I's interpretation. This is what it says right after Jim's line, you're bluffing. Pam makes a playful gesture like, who knows? Jim stares at her intensely.
那是即兴发挥还是剧本写的？剧本里是这样写的。我们之间的那些小眼神。剧本里有一段场景描述，所以你们现在看到的其实是约翰和我的理解。吉姆的台词“你在虚张声势”之后，剧本上是这样写的：帕姆做一个顽皮的手势，仿佛在说：谁知道呢？吉姆热烈地盯着她。
She smiles her best enigmatic smile. Jim enjoys this woman so much he finally has to break eye contact and shake it off. Oh, so that was what John and I, we had to take that note in the script and that's what made that scene. Oh, that's so good. I love that.
她露出自己最具神秘感的微笑。吉姆太享受这个女人了，最后不得不移开视线，摇摇头甩掉这种感觉。哦，所以这就是约翰和我，我们得消化剧本里的这个注解，从而成就了那个场景。哦，太棒了。我很喜欢。
Yeah. I love that. Well, I have a question that's not related to you guys flirting, but at 19 minutes, 26 seconds, what the heck? So Kevin wears glasses when he plays poker, but he doesn't wear glasses to be an accountant? Angela, we literally got a fan question that said the same thing.
是的。我很喜欢。不过我有一个与你们调情无关的问题，在19分26秒，这到底是怎么回事？凯文打扑克时戴着眼镜，但他当会计时怎么不戴眼镜？安吉拉，我们真的收到了一个粉丝提问，问了完全一样的问题。
What's up? My theory about that is that he doesn't care about being an accountant. I know. But as he tells us, he has won one of the satellite games in the World Series of Poker. He's an avid poker player this guy. He's a different person when he's playing poker.
怎么回事？我对此的理论是，他根本不在乎当会计。我知道。但正如他告诉我们的，他在世界扑克大赛中赢过一场卫星赛。这家伙是个狂热的扑克玩家。他打扑克时简直判若两人。
He's a smart person when he's playing poker. But also when he's playing in his band, he wears a hat. I know. Like when he comes to the barbecue, he's got a hat. He's got a whole persona outside of the office that is very different than what we see on a daily basis. Oh, for sure. For sure.
他打扑克时是个精明的人。而且他在乐队演出时，也会戴一顶帽子。我知道。比如他来参加烧烤派对时，就戴着一顶帽子。他在办公室之外拥有整套与我们平时日常所见截然不同的为人处世风格。哦，绝对是的。绝对是的。
I want to follow this guy around. I feel, is he putting us all on so that he doesn't really have to do work? What's happening, Kevin? OK. We have to talk about 20 minutes, three seconds. Carol and Jan are now side by side at the bar. Oh, yeah.
我想跟着这家伙混了。我觉得，他是不是在糊弄我们，好让他不用真正干活？凯文，这到底是怎么回事？好吧。我们得聊聊20分3秒。卡罗尔和简现在并肩站在酒吧台前。哦，对。
OK, so I took a screen grab of them standing side by side. You know I'm friends with Nancy, Steve's wife. I just adore her so much. I texted her the photo and I'm like, Nancy, this is how I'm starting my morning. And she was like, oh my god. She said, first of all, WTF with my hair. I said, Nancy, what do you remember about shooting these scenes?
好吧，我截了她们俩并肩站着的图。你知道我和南希（史蒂夫的妻子）是朋友。我太喜欢她了。我把照片发给她，对她说，南希，我就是这样开始我的早晨的。然后她说，哦，天哪。她说，首先，我的发型是怎么回事（WTF）。我说，南希，你对拍摄这些场景有什么记忆吗？
And she said, oh my gosh, well, our kids were six and three. So I had very few functioning brain cells at that point. And I said, well, Nancy, what was it like working with Steve? And she said, Jan, I was so intimidated because he's so good. I mean, he was really nice to me, of course. But I've sort of, you know, I had retired. And having our kids, that's what I was doing. I was being a mom, so I felt a little rusty.
她说，哦天哪，好吧，我们的孩子当时六岁和三岁。所以我那时正常运转的脑细胞寥寥无几。然后我说，好吧，南希，和史蒂夫一起工作是什么感觉？她说，简，我当时太紧张了，因为他太优秀了。我的意思是，他对我真的很好，当然。不过我差不多，你知道的，我已经退居幕后了。带我们的孩子就是我当时在做的事。我当时在当全职妈妈，所以我觉得自己有点生疏。
But it was so much fun. Oh, she is so great. And Steve's face would just light up every time she came to set, either if she was in a scene or if she was just coming by with the kids for a visit. I mean, his adoration of her would just go all across his face. They just were the cutest of cutie-cutes as a couple. They are an adorable couple.
但真的非常有趣。哦，她太棒了。每次她来到片场，史蒂夫的脸都会瞬间亮起来，不管是她有戏份，还是仅仅带着孩子过来探班。我的意思是，他对她的爱意简直溢于言表。他们作为伴侣，绝对是可爱至极的最萌情侣。他们是一对非常般配的伴侣。
They are so sweet with one another. I just love them so much. I would get so excited too when Nancy got to be in scenes because we were often in hair and makeup at the same time. We would just gab and gab and gab. I just adore that lady. So now Michael is at the craps table. And he has both Carol and Jan blow on the dice for luck.
他们彼此相处得太甜了。我太喜欢他们了。每当南希有戏份时，我也会兴奋得不行，因为我们俩经常同时在化妆间。我们就会一直不停地闲聊闲聊闲聊。我太喜欢那位女士了。现在迈克尔来到了双骰子赌桌旁。他让卡罗尔和简都在骰子上吹气来求好运。
So awkward. So weird. So weird. And then this is where Dwight starts peppering Jan with questions about where are you staying tonight? He's naming all the motels. And then Dwight has this line where he's like, oh, were you planning to stay with Michael?
太尴尬了。太诡异了。太诡异了。然后这就是德怀特开始连珠炮似地向简抛出问题的地方：你今晚住哪儿？他把所有的汽车旅馆名字都点了一遍。接着德怀特说了句台词，类似：哦，你原本打算和迈克尔住一起吗？
Well, that was not in the script. Oh, it wasn't? No. No. I feel like that when I heard that, I went to the script to look because I'm like, that sounds like a rain improv to me. That's brilliant, rain.
好吧，这可不在剧本里。哦，不在吗？不在。我觉得当我听到那句台词时，我还去翻了剧本查看，因为我想，这听起来太像雷恩的即兴发挥了。太精彩了，雷恩。
So good. So good. I'm giving that to rain. Yes, so good. I think she was legitimately surprised that he said it. Yeah. I texted Malora. I told her she's so fantastic in this episode.
太棒了。我把这功劳记给雷恩。是的，太棒了。我觉得她听到他说这话时是真的感到了惊讶。是的。我给玛洛拉发了短信。我告诉她在这集里表现得太棒了。
You just really feel Jan's desperation. And then you feel her self-loathing. It's, oh, it's so layered. So now we go over to the poker table with Kevin and Phyllis. Mm-hmm. Phyllis the flapper. Phyllis the flapper. Phyllis the flapper.
你真的能感受到简的绝望。然后你能感受到她对自己的厌恶。这，哦，层次太丰富了。现在我们转向凯文和菲莉丝所在的扑克桌。嗯哼。玩牌的菲莉丝。玩牌的菲莉丝。玩牌的菲莉丝。
He goes all in against Phyllis. And she wins with a flush. But she thought she only had ace high. But no, she had a flush to the ace. And she is like, I have all the clovers. I texted Phyllis and I said, Phyllis, what do you remember about that poker game? And she wrote me and said, oh, I loved the poker game.
他向菲莉丝全押了。而她用同花顺赢了。但她以为自己只有A高牌。然而并没有，她拿到了以A为顶张的同花。她当时说，我拿到了所有的梅花。我给菲莉丝发短信说，菲莉丝，你对那场扑克牌局有什么记忆？她回信告诉我，哦，我太喜欢那场扑克牌局了。
Brian's face as Kevin was priceless when I won. And then she wrote, I also love watching Pam and Jim Flirt as they played, because it looked real, because they're such good actors. Aw. Phyllis. I know. She's the sweetest.
当我赢了的时候，布莱恩扮演的凯文的表情简直无价。然后她写道，我也很喜欢看帕姆和吉姆边玩边调情，因为看起来太真实了，因为他们是那么优秀的演员。啊。菲莉丝。我知道。她人最好。
She's the sweetest. She said it was a priceless episode. My love to you and Jenna. Aw. Well, listen, you know what? Jan is going to walk outside at 22 minutes, 37 seconds, because she is just over it. And she's outside smoking.
她人太好了。她说这是一集无价的剧集。向你和詹娜表达我的爱。啊。好吧，听着，你知道吗？简要在22分37秒走到外面去，因为她实在是受够了。她在外面抽烟。
And Jim walks out. And Lady, I don't know if you remember this, but at the time when this aired, so many people thought that Jim and Jan were maybe going to hook up in this moment. And they were freaking out on all the message boards. Oh my god. Yeah.
然后吉姆走了出去。天哪，我不知道你还记不记得，但在这一集播出的时候，好多人都以为吉姆和简在这个时刻可能会勾搭上。他们在所有的留言板上都快急疯了。哦天哪。是的。
I remember like, oh no. Oh no, are they going to hook up? But no, they're just having a heart to heart. And then you find out the stakes for Jim, right? That he, she's like, have you told anyone? Because he's going to transfer. But people thought they might hook up. And they were all like, no.
我记得当时大家都在想，哦不。哦不，他们要勾搭上了吗？但并没有，他们只是在进行一场走心的交心。然后你发现了吉姆的利害关系，对吧？他，她说，你告诉过别人了吗？因为他要调职了。但人们真的以为他们会勾搭上。大家都在那儿喊，不要啊。
Yeah. So now we go back inside. Bob Vance is making an announcement. He is going to announce who the big winner of the night is. He said it's Creed Bratton. OK. And he wins the refrigerator. And Creed says, I've never owned a refrigerator.
是的。所以现在我们回到里面。鲍勃·万斯正在发表讲话。他要宣布今晚的最大赢家是谁。他说那是克里德·布拉顿。好吧。他赢得了那台冰箱。然后克里德说，我从来没拥有过冰箱。
Oh my gosh. This is his first one. The mini fridge is his first refrigerator. So here we go, guys. We are to the jam-tastic part of this episode. There is going to be a big moment in the parking lot. There's going to be a big moment in the office. So we thought we better call John Krasinski.
哦天哪。这是他的第一台。迷你冰箱是他的第一台冰箱。好啦，各位。我们来到这集的“满屏吉姆与帕姆”高潮部分了。停车场将有一个大场面。办公室里也将有一个大场面。所以我们觉得最好还是给约翰·卡拉辛斯基打个电话。
That's right. We didn't feel like we could talk about these scenes without him. So we did. We called him and he joined us. So guys, this is like we chitty chatted with John for a good 45 minutes. We're going to let it play out here for you.
没毛病。我们觉得如果没有他，我们就无法谈论这些场景。所以我们就这么做了。我们给他打了电话，他加入了我们。所以大家，我们和约翰闲聊了足足45分钟。我们打算在这里为你播放这段录音。
Enjoy. Guys, I watched an office episode for the first time. It's so long for this. Yeah. I haven't watched one for a little while now. And that one in particular, that's some heavy machinery of content. Yeah.
好好享受吧。大家伙儿，我这是生平第一次看《办公室》的一集。这已经是好久以前的事了。是啊。我已经有一小段时间没看过了。而那一集特别震撼，里面有大量重磅内容。是啊。
Yeah. That was some heavy machinery. We just threw you in the deep end, John. We were like, here, watch this one. Yeah, seriously. And I was like, first of all, I went through a time portal. I was like, who is that child? And I was talking about Jenna.
没错。那可真是重磅内容。我们直接把你扔到了深水区，约翰。我们当时就像是，给，看这一集。没错，说真的。我当时想，首先，我仿佛穿越到了时间之门。我想，那个孩子是谁？我当时说的是珍娜。
And then I saw some furry, you know, wood nymph come in looking like me. Man, we were young once, weren't we? Wasn't that nice? Yeah. Well, man, that was nice way back then. This is the first time I've watched Casino Night since it aired.
然后我看到一些毛茸茸的，你知道的，森林仙女走进来，长得就像我一样。天哪，我们曾经都很年轻，不是吗？那不是很美好吗？是的。好吧，天哪，那时候真的很美好。这是自我播出以来我第一次看《赌场之夜》。
Same. Yeah. Did we watch it at Greg's? I think we did. We did. We did. I wrote in my journal that he had a viewing party and we all went over.
我也是。对啊。我们是在格雷格家看的吗？我想是的。我们确实在那看。我们在那看的。我在日记里写过，他举办了一个观影派对，我们都过去了。
Oh my god, you have a journal? What am I doing with my life? Does she have a journal? Let me show you what my mic sits on so I can reach it because I'm shorty. Like seven journals. Like with Holly Hobby on the front. John, that's who I was.
哦天哪，你竟然有日记？我这辈子都在干什么？她有日记吗？让我给你看看我的麦克风放在什么上面，这样我才能够得着，因为我是个小个子。大概有七本笔记。封面好像还有霍莉·霍比。约翰，我以前就是那样的人。
Oh my god. Wait, who you were, that seems like a current journal that is being written about right now. I'm writing right now. By the way, speaking of Polly Pocket or whatever, Holly Hobby, either one of those E's, it made me think of that kid sister thing before I signed on. I was like, I had all these like sputtering memories
哦天哪。等等，你以前是谁，这听起来像是一本正在被实时书写的现代日记。我现在正在写。顺便说一句，说到波莉口袋或者别的什么，霍莉·霍比，这两个E开头的名字中的任何一个，让我想起了在我签约之前的那种小妹妹的事情。我当时就像是，我所有这些断断续续的记忆
that were like, remember this? And I blacked out for about 20 minutes. OK, so I told on the podcast that we would do bits between scenes, kind of keep us going, that you really kept us all going. You really did. And then I said, we would do this kid sister big brother bit. And Jenna was like, wait, where did that come from?
就像是，还记得这个吗？我失忆了大约20分钟。好吧，所以我曾在播客上说过，我们会在场景之间即兴表演一些小段子，有点像让我们保持状态，你真的让我们所有人保持了活力。你真的是。然后我说，我们会做这个小妹妹大哥哥的段子。然后珍娜就说，等等，这从何说起？
What was that about? You were like 1983 is where it came from. I know, but John, wasn't it because there was like a doll that was about my height? Oh no, you were the identical replica of kid sister. And they had, it was a kid, was it big brother? No, something. I would go, you, I would yell around the time.
这到底是怎么回事？你当时说这来自于1983年。我明白，但是约翰，难道不是因为有一个差不多我身高大小的娃娃吗？哦不，你简直就是小妹妹的复刻版。他们有一个，那是一个小孩，是叫大哥哥吗？不，别的什么。我当时会喊，你，我会在那个时候到处大喊。
No, there was a boy one and then they came out with a girl one that looked exactly like you. And I was at a store one day and saw it on a toy store like shelf. And I took a photo of myself standing next to it and I sent it to you. You were like, oh my god. Oh, I remember that.
不，有一个男孩款，然后他们推出了一款女孩款，长得跟你一模一样。有一天我在一家店里，在玩具店的货架上看到了它。我拍下了自己站在它旁边的一张照片，然后发给了你。你当时说，哦天哪。哦，我想起来了。
Yes. But also you're the exact size of it compared to me especially. You're like perfect. And I remember one day, didn't you do like the stiff arms and stuff? And I like picked you up and you were like, oh, it was great. It was good times. Someone, a fan wrote in and said, if you ever came on,
是的。而且特别是跟我的身高相比，你和它的大小完全一致。你简直太完美了。我记得有一天，你不是还摆出那种僵硬的胳膊之类的动作吗？然后我把你抱起来，你就像是，哦，那感觉太棒了。那是一段美好的时光。有人，一个粉丝写信说，如果你什么时候来，
could you and I do the bit? And I was like, well, it's a pretty. Kid sister. Big brother. Oh, there it is. There it is. Jenna, what jokes did we have? We didn't get along well.
你和我能表演那个小段子吗？我当时想，好吧，这挺经典的。小妹妹。大哥哥。哦，来了。就是这样。珍娜，我们有什么笑话来着？我们以前关系可不太好。
What was it for us? Oh, boy. What were our bits? What were our bits? Did we have bits? We had so many bits. You know what I remember bits wise was many different inside jokes of like writing on post-it notes and like all my memos
我们之间有什么？噢，天哪。我们的段子是什么？我们的段子是什么？我们有段子吗？我们有超级多的段子。我记忆中的段子是各种各样的内部笑话，比如在便利贴上写字，还有我所有的备忘录
that I had to hand to you for corporate. I always had something written on them. John, you played one prank on me in the whole nine years of the office, like one like really fully formed good thought out prank. It was at Shrewt Farms. And you and I had this scene where we had to drive up to the farmhouse several times.
我都得交给你作为公司公文。我上面总是有写东西。约翰，在《办公室》整整九年的时间里，你只对我恶作剧过一次，就像那种真正完整、构思巧妙的恶作剧。那是在施鲁特农场。你和我有一场戏，我们得开着车好几次靠近农舍。
And we're doing it. And I am getting increasingly more hot. I'm like warm. I'm sweating. I'm like, oh my god. I'm like, it's so hot. And we had to turn off the AC for sound. And you were like, yeah, I don't know.
我们在拍这个。我越来越热了。我感觉很暖和。我在出汗。我当时想，哦天哪。我心想，太热了。为了收音，我们必须关掉空调。你当时就说，对啊，我不知道。
I'm OK, but you're hot, huh? And I'm like, I'm so hot. This went on for like 15 minutes. And then all of a sudden you start snickering. And you had turned on my seat warmer. All the way to the hottest setting. Oh my god, that was late in the run, wasn't it? That was late in the run.
我挺好的，不过你很热，对吧？我心想，我热死了。这种情况持续了大约15分钟。然后突然之间你开始吃吃地笑。你竟然打开了我的座椅加热器。开到了最高档。哦天哪，那是拍摄后期发生的事吧？那是拍摄后期。
And I, but I was so excited because whenever we would go on talk shows, they would always ask us if we played pranks on each other. And I would always say no. And I mean, not really. I mean, besides just like little jokes on Post-it notes or something. I'm terrible.
而且我，但我当时太兴奋了，因为每当我们上脱口秀节目时，他们总是问我们是否互相恶作剧。而我总是说没有。我的意思是，其实没有。我是说，除了在便利贴上开点小玩笑之类的。我太糟糕了。
Not really. I'm terrible at pranks. Now we weren't pranky, you know? But then finally, after you did that in the car, I was like, oh my gosh, this is great. I can finally have a prank to talk about. And you know what's sad about that prank? What's sad about that prank?
其实没有。我超不擅长恶作剧。现在我们不搞恶作剧，你知道的？但后来，你在车里干了那事之后，我心想，哦天哪，这太棒了。我终于有一个可以拿出来说的恶作剧了。你知道那个恶作剧最可悲的是什么吗？最可悲的是什么？
I realized that I am such a bad prankster that I stole that prank from Clooney when we were doing Leatherheads. He did that to me. So that's how unoriginal I am. I was like, I'm going to take George Clooney's bed and do it to Jenna. And I thought that would make me cool.
我意识到我是一个如此糟糕的恶作剧者，以至于我在拍《皮草大豪客》时，把那个恶作剧从克鲁尼那里偷了过来。他对我也这么干过。所以我就是这么没有创意。我当时想，我要用乔治·克鲁尼的那招来对付珍娜。我以为这会让我显得很酷。
Yeah, so basically you're that. I got a recycled prank. You got Clooney is what you got. I did, one degree of separation. I think that prank just keeps getting cooler. Like that's pretty fancy. I think so too, yeah. That's a good prank.
对，所以基本上你就是那个。我拿到了一个二手恶作剧。你用的是克鲁尼的招，就是这样。我确实用了，相差一度。我觉得那个恶作剧听起来越来越酷了。就像那样挺高档的。我也这么觉得，是的。那是个好恶作剧。
Let's get into the meat of your interview here, John. I thought we were doing pretty good. We were, but we should intro you a little. John, thank you so much for coming on the show. We always like to ask our guests a little bit about how they came to be on the office. And I know you've told this story like a million times, but is it true that you were originally
我们来切入你访谈的核心吧，约翰。我觉得我们之前表现得挺好的。我们确实挺好，不过我们应该稍微介绍你一下。约翰，非常感谢你来到节目。我们总是喜欢问我们的嘉宾一些关于他们是如何加入《办公室》的经历。我知道你这个故事已经讲过一百万遍了，但这是真的吗，你最初被
asked to audition for Dwight? Yes, I was. And that reminds me that about six seasons into the show, someone was like, I love how you say Dwight. And I was like, how do you say it? And they were like Dwight. And I was like, I know Dwight. And they were like, nope, Dwight.
邀请去试镜德怀特（Dwight）？是的，我是。这让我想起大约在剧集拍到第六季时，有人说，我喜欢你发“德怀特”这个音的方式。我说，你是怎么发音的？他们说德怀特（Dwight）。我说，我知道是德怀特（Dwight）。他们说，不对，是德怀特（Dwight）。
And I was like, no, no, I'm saying it right. Dwight. And they were like, nope, it's not. So yes, I auditioned or no, I was offered to come in and audition for the role of Dwight. And I was so excited. I had met Alison Jones randomly out in LA on a general meeting when I had $0 to my name.
我说，不对，不对，我发音很对。Dwight。他们说，不对，根本不是。所以是的，我试镜了，或者说不，是他们邀请我去试镜德怀特这个角色。我当时太兴奋了。我在洛杉矶的一次常规见面会上偶然遇到了艾莉森·琼斯，当时我身上只有0美元。
And she said, something's coming on our first meeting. Our only meeting. She said, something's coming called the office. You'd be great for it. I said, great. So then I got back to New York. And they said, there's this show called The Office. And I was like, oh my god, Alison Jones, the greatest human
她说，在我们的第一次见面时。我们唯一的见面。她说，有一个叫《办公室》的节目要推出了。你非常适合它。我说，太棒了。然后我回到了纽约。他们说，有这么个节目叫《办公室》。我就想，哦天哪，艾莉森·琼斯，这个世界上最伟大的人
ever told me about this. And they said, you're going in for the role of Dwight. And I had been a huge fan of the British show. And I was like, I don't know, man. I don't know if I'm right for that role. And so I weirdly have no idea what I was thinking. I said, you know what? I read the pilot and I said, you know what?
曾经跟我提过这个。他们说，你要去试镜德怀特这个角色。我之前一直是这部英国剧集的超级粉丝，当时我就想，我不知道，伙计。我不知道自己是否适合这个角色。所以奇怪的是，我不知道当时脑子里在想什么。我说，你知道吗？我读了试播集剧本，然后我说，你知道吗？
I'm going to put my best foot forward. Let me know when they're casting gyms. And I remember the response from the MDC casting director to my manager at the time was, no, but honestly, who does he think he is? Like passing up an audition, an opportunity to audition. And lo and behold, I thought it was over. And I think it was like five, six weeks later that they called.
我打算全力以赴。等他们选吉姆的时候通知我。我记得当时MDC选角导演对我经纪人的回复是，不，说实话，他觉得自己是谁啊？居然拒绝试镜，拒绝一个试镜的机会。结果没想到，我以为这事黄了。然后大概过了五、六周，他们打电话来了。
And they were like, all right, they're looking for gyms now and they'll have you back. And then I went in. And that's so crazy. And then when we finally did our screen test, you were living in New York and you had to fly to LA for that screen test. With all these New Yorkers that were auditioning,
他们说，行，他们现在正在找吉姆，会让你回去。然后我就去了。这太疯狂了。然后当我们终于进行试镜的时候，你住在纽约，为了那场试镜你不得不飞到洛杉矶。和所有这些参加试镜的纽约人一起，
which was so much fun. I remember I took the plane with Jim Gaffigan, who was auditioning for a role. And it was like laughing. I mean, just was surrounded by heroes on the plane and then got to the callback or the test or whatever they called it. Because I'm so experienced now.
这太有趣了。我记得我和吉姆·加菲根坐同一架飞机，他当时在为一个角色试镜。大家都在笑。我的意思是，飞机上全是被我视为英雄的人，然后到了回调试镜或者正式试镜，或者他们管这叫什么的环节。因为我现在经验太丰富了。
I have no idea what I'm talking about. But I remember getting in this big room. And it was the waiting room of where we actually shot our pilot. I'm sure you guys have covered that. But where we shot our pilot is what they measured down to the quarter inch or centimeter to make our set, this building that existed. We took an existing building.
我根本不知道自己在说啥。但我记得走进那个大房间。那是我们实际拍摄试播集的休息室。我相信你们大家肯定都聊过这个。但我们拍摄试播集的地方，他们把现有的这座建筑按四分之一英寸或厘米的精度进行了测量来搭建我们的布景，我们用的是一栋现成的建筑。
And I remember sitting basically where Ryan's desk. No, where Mindy's desk was, like Toby and Mindy's desk was, I was sitting against that wall. And I saw all these other people coming in. I'd been there for an hour or two hours. And all the other people were the LA people. I realized they had separated us. And so they were asking the New York people
我记得我基本上坐在瑞恩的桌子……不对，是米兰迪的桌子，就像托比和米兰迪的桌子那样，我靠着那堵墙坐着。我看到其他所有人陆续进来。我已经在那待了一个小时或两小时了。其他所有人都是洛杉矶本地人。我意识到他们把我们分开了。所以他们要求纽约人
to leave after they were done. And then I was the last New York person. And I saw all these LA people in. And I started to get super self-conscious. I am not a confident person. And I was like, oh, my god, this is so embarrassing. I'm the only New Yorker here. Because everybody was like, hey, Johnny, Tim,
结束后就离开。然后我是最后一个离开的纽约人。我看到所有这些洛杉矶人进来。我开始变得超级不自在。我可不是个自信的人。当时我就想，天哪，这也太尴尬了。我是这里唯一的纽约人。因为每个人都在打招呼，嗨，强尼，蒂姆，
like greeting each other. And I was sitting on a floor. So I went on to the set because all the producers were hiding in the background. And I said, I'm so sorry. I think someone forgot to tell me to go home. And from behind a fake wall, I remember hearing a lot of chair moving and stuff
就像互相问候一样。我当时坐在地板上。所以我走到布景里，因为所有制片人都躲在背景里，我说，真对不起。我想有人忘了叫我回家了。然后我听到一堵假墙后面传来一阵搬椅子之类的声音，
and banging against the wall. And it was Greg trying to get out of his chair and find the entrance to get back on set. And he was like, nope, hold on one second. Hold on one second, please. Hold on one second. And I heard Terry Weinberg be like, no, no, no, no, no, don't go.
还有撞到墙的声音。那是格雷格在努力从椅子里站起来，寻找回到布景的入口。他说，不，等一下。请等一下。请等一下。我听到特里·温伯格说，不，不，不，不，别走。
And then I went back out to the waiting room, super freaked out. And I saw Jenna walk in the door. And she was like, as soon as I saw you walk in, Jen, I know I told the story at building time. So people are like, we get it. We've seen behind the scenes. I genuinely had like a metaphysical event
然后我又回到了休息室，吓得要死。我看到珍娜走了进来。她就像是，珍，我一看到你走进来，我就知道，我在建设时间里讲过这个故事了。所以大家可能会想，我们懂的。我们看过幕后花絮了。我真的经历了一次类似超自然体验的事件，
where I was like, oh, that's who's in the show. That person will be in the show. And so they held me back. He went in with a bunch of people. And I remember thinking, if I don't go in with her, I'm screwed. And that's when I went on the thing and said, you should let me go.
当时我就想，哦，那就是剧里的人。那个人会出现在剧里。所以他们留下了我。他跟一群人一起进去了。我记得当时想，如果我不和她一起进去，我就死定了。就在那时，我走上去说，你们应该让我走。
And they said, no, no, no, there's one more person we want you to audition with. And it was you. And I thought, oh my god, you're saying there's a chance. Because if I'm in with you, I knew I had a shot. Oh my god, John, I can go back to that moment that I saw you at the audition and I had that exact same reaction.
他们说，不，不，不，还有最后一个人我们想让你一起试镜。那就是你。我想，哦天哪，你是说还有机会。因为如果我和你一起，我知道我有胜算了。天哪，约翰，我能回到那个在试镜时看到你的瞬间，我当时有了完全相同的反应。
It was, I've tried to describe it to people what it was like to audition with you. And the best explanation I could come up with was like, what if you walked into a room and music started playing and you and another person just started dancing in unison even though you'd never met? That's what it was like auditioning with you. Wow, that's really way more beautiful than what I would
那是，我曾试图向别人描述和你一起试镜是什么感觉。我能想到的最好解释就是，如果你走进一个房间，音乐开始响起，你和另一个人甚至在素不相识的情况下就开始齐头并进地跳舞？这就是和你一起试镜的感觉。哇，这真的比我想象的要美妙得多，
say, which is like, I felt like I could see the future. Like, I was like, it actually gave me anxiety because I was like, she's so on the show. It's so weird that I'm like watching a piece get in. And I remember, I'm sure you remember too, but after our audition and I loved auditioning with you, we were walking through the kitchen. And I said, because that was the way out.
我想说的是，我觉得我能看到未来。就像是，这甚至让我感到焦虑，因为我想，她绝对在剧里。这种感觉太诡异了，就像我看着一个拼图拼上去一样。我记得，我相信你也记得，在我们试镜之后，我超喜欢和你一起试镜，我们正穿过厨房。
And I said, I just got to let you know, I think that you're going to get this part of your perfect for this. And you seem to remember, you said the same thing to me. I don't because I blacked out. I was trying to not look you in the eyes. I was so excited that you said that because I felt like I had wanted to say that to you,
我说，因为那是出口。我说，我必须得告诉你，我觉得你能拿到这个角色，你太适合了。你好像也记得，你也对我说过同样的话。我不记得了，因为我当时大脑一片空白。我极力避免跟你对视。我太高兴你能这么说了，因为我觉得我一直想对你这么说，
but I didn't have the courage because I didn't know you. You were like, essentially a stranger to me. The only time we had really spoken or interacted was during our audition. So we were kind of silently walking back to the kitchen. And I was thinking in my head, should I tell him I think he's the best gym? Is that appropriate?
但我没有勇气，因为我并不认识你。你对我来说基本上是个陌生人。我们唯一真正说过话或有过互动的时候就是在试镜期间。所以我们一路默默无闻地走回厨房。我心里在想，我该不该告诉他我觉得他是最好的吉姆？这样合适吗？
Should I say you're the best gym? You're going to be gym? Or is that bad form? I don't know. What's the etiquette? And so when you said, I think you're going to get the role of Pam, my memory is that I was like, oh my god, I think you're
我该说你是最好的吉姆吗？你会成为吉姆吗？还是说这样做很不合规矩？我不知道。有什么礼仪吗？所以当你说，我觉得你会得到帕姆这个角色时，我的记忆是，我就像，哦天哪，我觉得你会
going to be gym. You're the best gym. You're my favorite gym. Like that I just like, bored and I had like this. Yeah, I was having a nosebleed at that time. Don't remember much. But I do remember this, though, that I always say this and people are like, yeah, whatever, but it's true.
成为吉姆。你是最棒的吉姆。你是我最喜欢的吉姆。就像我当时直接……而且我当时流鼻血了。记不太清了。但我确实记得这一点，我总是这么说，人们会觉得，好吧，随便吧，但这是真的。
I have a lottery ticket life ever since I was given the news that I was on that show. Everything changed in my life for every single way, not to get into a heady version. But not only every opportunity that I've ever had is from the show, I met my wife because she knew who I was in a restaurant for a show we never would have been in the same city or restaurant or anything.
自从我得到出演那部剧的消息以来，我过着彩票中奖一般的生活。我生活中的一切在各个方面都改变了，这并不是为了表现得多么深奥。不仅我得到的所有机会都来自于这部剧，我还遇到了我的妻子，因为她在一个餐厅里认出了我是谁，而对于一部剧来说，我们绝不可能在同一个城市、餐厅或任何地方相遇。
It's just so crazy how deep and crazy it goes. But I remember at the epicenter of it all, when I was told that I had the part, I actually jumped on a couch. And then again, this metaphysical thing came over me where I went, wait, wait, wait, one second. Did Jenna Fisher get the part of Pam? And they were like, we don't know.
这太疯狂了，这种联系有多深、多疯狂。但我记得这一切的核心，当我被告知我得到了这个角色时，我实际上兴奋得跳上了一沙发。然后再次，这种超自然的感觉向我袭来，我心想，等等，等等，等等，一秒钟。珍娜·费舍尔拿到帕姆的角色了吗？他们说，我们不知道。
We just told you your life changed. Are you happy enough with that? And I was like, no, you need to call them back and ask if Jenna got the part. Because I thought if you were on it, then I was going to be on one of the best things that I'll ever do in my life. And if they were like, no, Rhonda,
我们刚告诉你，你的人生改变了。你对此足够满意了吗？我说，不，你们得回个电话问问珍娜有没有拿到角色。因为我觉得如果你加入了，那我就将参与我一生中做过的最棒的事情之一。如果他们说，不，朗达，
something would ever got it. And I'd be like, no, not Rhonda. Well, when they called me and told me that I got the part, I had a very similar reaction and the first question I asked was, did John Krasinski get the role of Jim? Because I just felt like, I don't know if I can do Pam without you as Jim. So I was like, I need to know, did my partner in crime
随便什么人拿到了。那我会说，不，别是朗达。好吧，当他们打电话告诉我我得到了这个角色时，我有非常相似的反应，我问的第一个问题是，约翰·克拉辛斯基拿到吉姆的角色了吗？因为我只是觉得，如果没有你演吉姆，我不知道我能不能演好帕姆。所以我当时就想，我得知道，我的犯罪同伙
get this part? And they were like, yes, he did. And what's weird is that that's the first question he asked after he was told. That's amazing. And by the way, we never saw each other after the kitchen. I left. No, we didn't have each other's phone numbers.
拿到这个角色了吗？他们说，是的，他拿到了。奇怪的是，这也是他被告知后问的第一个问题。这太棒了。顺便说一句，我们在厨房之后就再也没见过彼此。我走了。不，我们当时没有彼此的电话号码。
We couldn't text each other or email. So it was like, then I just waited until the pilot table read when we were all reunited. Same with Rain. I only met Rain at the audition. And when I heard he got the role, I was like, well, that tracks because he was definitely the weirdest dude.
我们不能发短信或发邮件。所以就像是，然后我只能一直等着试播集剧本围读，那时我们才重新聚在一起。雷恩也是。我只在试镜时见过雷恩。当我听说他得到了这个角色时，我想，这很符合他的作风，因为他绝对是个最怪的家伙。
Oh my god. I remember thinking, I remember doing this audition with Rain where Greg asked me to ask him to cover my phones. And of course, he said to Rain under no circumstances will you cover his phones? And I remember being like, hey, Dwight, will you just cover my phone? I just got to go to the bathroom.
天哪。我记得我想，我记得和雷恩做过那次试镜，当时格雷格让我请他帮我代接电话。当然，他对雷恩说，无论在什么情况下都绝对不能帮他代接电话？我记得当时我说，嘿，德怀特，你能帮我接一下电话吗？我得去趟洗手间。
And he was like, sorry. And then pretended to close barn doors. And then I asked him again. And he did like shipping container doors. And I kept doing it. And by the end of it, not to Dwight to the actor Rain, I was like, you are infuriating. You're an infuriating human.
他说，对不起。然后假装关上仓库的大门。接着我又问了他一遍。他又做了一个像是集装箱大门的动作。我一直在重复这个。到了最后，我不是对演员雷恩说，而是对德怀特说，你太气人了。你是个气死人的家伙。
And I was like, he's going to get it. Well, oh my gosh, it is so good to talk to you. All of that just makes my heart happy, you guys, hearing all that. I don't know that I've heard snippets of those stories, but I've never heard all of it. And watched you guys tell it is actually really beautiful. Just go and say.
当时我就想，他肯定会懂的。天哪，跟你们聊天太棒了。听你们说这些，我的心都要融化了，伙计们。那些故事的片段我可能听说过，但全貌我从来没听过。看着你们把它们讲出来，其实真的非常美妙。只想这么说。
No, that's what I was going to say. I've actually never told those stories with you in, I was going to say, in person or not, in digital form. Same. I feel like we've told those stories separately on talk shows or interviews, but actually never told one another. Yeah, it's like there's always these things where you're like,
不，我正要说这个。其实我从来没有和你一起讲过这些故事，不管是当面还是以数字形式。我也是。我觉得我们之前在脱口秀或采访中都是分开讲这些故事的，但确实从来没有对彼此讲过。对，就好像总有这样一些时刻，你会想：
is that what happened? It's so interesting. So amazing. I have so many stories that I'm like, I wonder if people know that. It's like some of my favorite stuff is like sort of, I guess it's a secret, but I don't know. Oh, like one of my favorite stories
事情真的是这样吗？太有趣了。太神奇了。我有很多故事，有时候我在想，别人知道这些吗？我最喜欢的一些东西就好像是，某种程度上的秘密，不过我也不确定。哦，比如说我最喜欢的一个故事
that I haven't told you this story was when we rapped. By the way, how dare Greg Daniels do that rap? Remember that? When he was like, yeah, I just got to get you guys leave in the office a couple of times for, I got to cut it into the earlier part of the show. And we were all just totally goofing off and laughing, heading to like for Richard Design.
我还没跟你讲过这个故事，那就是我们说唱的时候。顺便说一句，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）怎么敢搞那个说唱？还记得吗？当时他说，好吧，我得让你们离开办公室几分钟，我得把它剪到节目早期的部分。我们当时都在那儿胡闹、大笑，准备去理查德设计公司。
And then when we came back, he was standing there all weird. Remember that? Yeah. And he was like, that was the last take of anything. And he was like, ladies and gentlemen, I just want to tell you that the show has concluded or the office is over. That's a wrap.
然后当我们回来时，他站在那里怪里怪气的。还记得吗？对。然后他说，那是任何镜头的最后一条了。接着他说，女士们先生们，我只想告诉你们，节目已经结束了，或者说办公室结束了。杀青了。
That's a wrap. And I was like, and I definitely threw up on my shoes. Someone took a picture of that moment. I don't know who it was, but all gave me that picture. We're disintegrating. We're like all of us. But he did, it was like some weird, incredibly smart move to like just, because we all knew it was coming.
杀青了。当时我想，我差点吐在鞋上。有人拍下了那一刻。我不知道是谁，但每个人都把那张照片发给我了。我们当时都在崩溃。就像我们所有人一样。但他那么做，真是一个怪异、极其聪明的举动， просто... 因为我们都知道那一天要来了。
And then he did the smartest thing by being like, oh, shoot. I got to do this one more thing. Like just get out of the office, walk a couple of times. I just need you to exit. And I remember Randall being weird, so he must have been in on it. And then when Greg came out, I remember we looked in all the crew, everyone that had been in Video Village
然后他做了最聪明的一件事，就是说：“哦，糟了。我还有最后一件事要做。”就像是“离开办公室，走上几圈。我只需要你们出去。”我还记得兰德尔（Randall）当时怪怪的，所以他肯定也参与其中了。然后当格雷格出来时，我记得我们看着所有的剧组人员，所有在“视频村”的人
had come out on the stage. And they were all sort of like, looked around. And I was just like, what's happening? We all ended together. It was so intense. It was like, I'm your dad, and I'm leaving you. And you were like, what? But the funny thing was that day,
都来到了舞台上。他们都在环顾四周。当时我就想，发生什么事了？我们所有人最后都聚在了一起。那种感觉太强烈了。就像是“我是你们的爸爸，我要离开你们了”。而你的反应是：“什么？”但有趣的是，那天
everybody was really emotional. And we had the rap party. And so everybody was like trying to get themselves together. And I think of myself as a somewhat moral person. And I had the weirdest idea when I got back to the trailer, I was crying like crazy. And I went, oh my god, there's one thing I want. It's like, what's the one thing you would want from the show?
每个人都情绪激动。而且我们还要办杀青派对。所以每个人都在极力控制自己的情绪。我自认为是一个还算遵纪守法的人。当我回到化妆车里时，我脑子里冒出了一个最奇怪的想法，当时我哭得稀里哗啦。然后我心想，天哪，我有一件想要的东西。就像是，你从这个节目里最想要的一样东西是什么？
And I ran back and stole the Dunder Mifflin sign that we all did talking heads, Sue. And I got, dude, and then I think I did tell you, Jenna, because I was like, so Catholic. I was like, most tell someone. And then we got to the party and I'll never forgive myself. I don't even know if he knows it. We're at the party and I saw Greg.
然后我跑回去，偷走了我们做“面对镜头采访”时用的那块邓德米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）招牌，苏。我拿到了，老兄，然后我想我一定告诉你了，珍娜，因为我太天主教徒了。我想，我必须得告诉某个人。然后我们到了派对上，我永远无法原谅自己。我甚至不知道他知不知道这事。我们在派对上，我看到了格雷格。
And I was like, Greg, thank you for my whole life. And like whatever. And he was like, yeah, yeah, no problem. And I was like, how are you doing? And he goes, ah, good. You know, I'm a little bummed. The one thing I wanted was the Dunder Mifflin sign. He goes, but someone took it.
然后我说：“格雷格，谢谢你给予我的一切。”之类的话。然后他回答：“啊，对，对，没问题。”我说：“你最近怎么样？”他回答：“唉，挺好的。你知道，我有点沮丧。我唯一想要的东西就是邓德米夫林招牌。”他说，“但有人把它拿走了。”
And literally my brain exploded. And I went, that sucks, man. Whoever did that, that sucks. I remember saying to him, I lied to my dad. I lied to my TV creator. Oh my god. I lied to his face. I remember you loading out your trailer and I walked out.
简直是晴天霹雳，我的大脑瞬间爆炸了。然后我说：“那太糟了，老兄。不管是哪个混蛋干的，真够逊的。”我记得当时对他说我向我老爸撒了谎。我向我的电视剧主创撒了谎。天哪。我当着他的面撒了谎。我还记得你当时在收拾你的化妆车，我走了出去。
And I have a visual of you putting it in your car. It was very large. It was very large. Because I only had like a bath towel and that didn't even begin to cover it. It was just like, it was the worst heist of all time. And I also remember people being like, why is John leaving so fast?
我脑海里有一个画面，就是你把它放进你的车里。那东西非常大。非常大。因为我当时只有一条浴巾，那根本遮不住它。感觉就像，那是史上最逊的抢劫案。我也记得当时有人问：“约翰怎么走得这么快？”
And I was like, don't look at me. Like as I drove out of the parking lot, it was so weird. Do you remember the big sign that, well, it was like a fake painting of me looking angry that hung in the senator's house? Oh, yeah. The art department gave that to me. It's enormous.
当时我就想：别看我。当我把车开出停车场时，那种感觉太诡异了。你还记得那张挂在参议员家里的巨型海报吗？好吧，那其实是一幅画着我看起来很生气的假肖像？哦，对。美术部门把那个送给我了。那东西巨大无比。
It's the size of a small love seat sofa. If we're sharing secrets, I'll say that I asked if I could have Pam's water color of Dunder Mifflin. And I was told officially from production that I could not have it because it was going to be cataloged as part of the set decoration. And it would be stored at NBC.
有双人小沙发的尺寸那么大。既然我们在分享秘密，那我也要说，我曾问过能否把帕姆的那幅邓德米夫林水彩画拿走。制作方给我的官方回复是，我不能拿走它，因为它将被归档为布景装饰的一部分。它会被存放在NBC（全国广播公司）。
And no, I couldn't have it. I was really heartbroken because besides a couple of trinkets on my desk and like a few pieces of wardrobe, I really hadn't saved anything else. That was really the one thing I wanted. And oh my gosh, I'm going to cry a little bit. As I was leaving, Phil Shea ran up to me and he said, here, you should have this.
所以不行，我不能拥有它。我当时真的很心碎，因为除了我桌上的几个小摆设和几件戏服之外，我真的什么都没留下来。那真的是我唯一想要的东西。然后，天哪，我快要哭了。当我正要离开时，菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）朝我跑过来，他说：“给你，这个你拿着。”
I made a color photo of it. They'll never know. I have the original in my house. Oh my god. That's amazing. Dude, Phil Shea is the reason I have anything. He sent me a box like years, like three or four years later of my bag, my nameplate.
我复印了一张彩色的。他们永远不会发现。原件在我家里。哦，天哪。太厉害了。老兄，菲尔·谢伊就是我能拥有任何东西的原因。几年后，大概是三四年后，他寄给我一个箱子，里面有我的包、我的名牌。
Is that your satchel that you would use? Yeah, my satchel, my nameplate, and the teapot, bro. Oh, you have the teapot. You have the teapot. You have the teapot. We have been wondering you have the teapot. Teapot, son. Son of a gun.
那是你平时用的那个斜挎包吗？对，我的斜挎包、我的名牌，还有那个茶壶，兄弟。哦，你有那个茶壶。你有那个茶壶。你有那个茶壶。我们一直在猜到底是谁拿了那个茶壶。茶壶啊，老兄。真是个机灵鬼。
Wow, you have it. Oh, man, I thought you knew that. I didn't know it was a great caper. Shea said, I have always wondered who got the teapot. Who got that teapot? I've always wondered. You know what's so funny is I had the greatest idea, because I heard your amazing podcast about the teapot episode.
哇，原来在你这儿。哦，天哪，我还以为你知道呢。我当时不知道这是一场惊天大盗窃。谢伊说：“我一直很好奇是谁拿了那个茶壶。到底是谁拿了那个茶壶？我一直很好奇。”你知道最搞笑的是什么吗？我当时有个绝妙的主意，因为我听了你关于茶壶那一集的精彩播客。
And I was going to take a picture of it in my room and totally forgot. I wanted to post it right after I had heard your episode. Oh my gosh, that would have blown my mind. I'm sure there's a couple, because in case anyone broke, you could probably get one, I'm sure. I know, but you have the teapot. That's huge.
我本来打算在房间里给它拍张照片，结果给忘得精光。我本来想在听完你们那一集之后立刻发出来的。天哪，那绝对会让我惊掉下巴。我确信肯定还有好几个，因为万一有人弄坏了，你大概还能再弄到一个，我敢肯定。我知道，但你拥有那个茶壶。那太牛了。
So there you go. So, John, we are currently on the scene outside in the parking lot, where Jim Roy just took off in his truck. Yeah, said, told me to keep an eye on you. Remember that? Yeah. Jenna's dressed as a bridesmaid.
所以你看。所以，约翰，我们目前在室外的停车场现场，吉姆·哈尔珀特（Jim Roy）刚刚开着他的卡车绝尘而去。对，（迈克尔）叫我盯着你。还记得吗？对。珍娜穿着伴娘礼服。
Jenna looks like a bridesmaid. I remember talking to Jenna about this a couple times about, like, how Jenna's take on it was like, or for Pam's take, whatever. She was like, little saucy of Jim to be like, you got it. Like, a little devious right from the beginning. Like, this nice guy was like, oh, you bet. I'll take care of her.
珍娜看起来就像个伴娘。我记得和珍娜讨论过好几次这个场景，关于珍娜当时对它的理解，或者说帕姆的理解之类的。她当时觉得，吉姆说“包在我身上”显得有点轻浮。就好像从一开始就有点鬼主意。这个好人当时就像是“哦，没问题。我会照顾好她的。”
Oh, I'll take care of her. Oh, I'll take care of her. No, I remember that. That moment in particular was insane for so many reasons, because I remember how, again, I'm going to keep talking about this metaphysical thing, but I remember that the cells of my body were really buzzing because I saw the crew running around
“哦，我会照顾好她的。”“哦，我会照顾好她的。”不，我记得。那一刻之所以特别疯狂，原因有很多，因为我记得，再次强调，我要继续谈论这种形而上的东西，我记得我身体里的细胞当时真的在兴奋地颤抖，因为我看到剧组人员在四处奔跑
and deciding where to hide the cameras. And Ken Quapas was our director and was phenomenal and making it feel like it's no big deal. We're just doing a scene of a show that'll never be seen. And then you're like, I think that's going to be more than that. And he was like, who cares? Just do it. Like, he was trying to keep it so low.
并商量着把摄像机藏在哪里。肯·夸帕斯（Ken Quapas）是我们的导演，他表现得太出色了，让一切看起来都无足轻重。我们只是在拍一个永远不会被播出的剧集的一场戏。然后你会想，我觉得事情没那么简单。而他的反应是：谁在乎呢？拍就是了。他当时尽量把阵仗压得极低。
And I remember you and I were in a stairwell or something waiting. And everybody was deciding, do you do the cameras? Can they see the cameras? Can they not see the cameras? Meaning, Jim and Pam, can they see the cameras, whatever? Are they aware of the documentary crew? And I remember, I think it was Ken, right, who just said,
我记得你和我当时在一个楼梯间之类的合影区域等待。每个人都在争论：摄像机放在哪？他们能看到摄像机吗？他们看不到摄像机吗？也就是说，吉姆和帕姆能看到摄像机吗，诸如此类的？他们意识到这是个纪录片剧组了吗？我记得，好像是肯吧？他当时说，
I think I'm going to make the decision that they don't. And I remember Matt. I think I remember this. Again, I'm elderly. But I feel like I feel like Ken placed the cameras and didn't tell us exactly where they were going to be. That sounds like Ken. Well, there was this big argument that went back to even
我想我决定让他们看不到。我记得马特。我好像记得这个。再说一次，我都老了。但我觉得，我觉得肯把摄像机架好了，但没有确切告诉我们它们会放在哪里。这很符合肯的风格。好吧，当时还有一个激烈的争论，甚至可以追溯到
when the script came out, which was, should we film this scene with video or with audio only? Like this idea. And I think the reason we were in a stairwell for a very long time, John, was because they were deciding if we should have walked inside and gone onto the stairwell and we said the lines. And right when we got to the end of the scene,
剧本刚出来的时候，那就是：我们应该用视频拍摄这场戏，还是只收音频？就是这种构思。我想我们在楼梯间待了很长时间的原因，约翰，是因为他们在决定我们是否应该走进去，走到楼梯间里然后再说台词。等我们说到这场戏的尾声时，
the camera would find us. And we would be looking at each other in silence. Yes, the idea was that Randall would be running to try to get it on film. Yes. And that was kind of like Greg wanted that. And like half the writers wanted that. Yeah.
摄像机会找到我们。然后我们会静静地看着彼此。对，原本的想法是兰德尔会一路小跑，试图把它拍到胶片上。对。而且格雷格就想要这种效果。差不多一半的编剧也想要这样。对。
Imagine how good the show could have been if that was the case. I know, but instead. We could have satiated. But then, and by the way, on Wikipedia, it claims that we shot that footage and it has never been seen, but that's not true. We never shot that. We only rehearsed it.
想象一下，如果真是那样，这个节目会有多棒。我知道，但结果却是……我们本可以得到满足的。但是，顺便说一句，维基百科上声称我们拍过那个素材，而且从未曝光，但这不是真的。我们根本没拍过那个版本。我们只排练过。
I don't remember ever shooting a version. Do you? Yeah, I thought we rehearsed it. And then what I do remember maybe vaguely is that Ken was like, and if we do that version, we'll have the audio. So don't worry about it. Remember, like I remember Ken, I think was saying to Greg, like, listen, Greg, the good news is if we do end up
我不记得我们拍过任何版本。你记得吗？对，我想我们只是排练过。然后我隐约记得的是，肯当时说：“如果我们拍那个版本，我们会有音频的。所以不用担心。”记得吗，我记得肯好像在对格雷格说：“听着，格雷格，好消息是如果我们最后真的
going that route, we will already have the audio. Let's just shoot it out here first. And it was like a Jedi mind trick to get Greg to go with it. Right. But I do remember that they did. Another reason we were in the stairwell was so that they were going to set the cameras outside. And when we came out, we wouldn't know where the cameras were.
走那条路，我们已经有音频了。我们先在这里拍外面这个版本吧。”这就像是一个绝地武士的心灵把戏，用来忽悠格雷格接受这个方案。对。但我确实记得他们这么做了。我们在楼梯间的另一个原因，是他们要把摄像机架在室外。当我们走出来时，我们不会知道摄像机在哪里。
Right. And I remember feeling very alone in the parking lot. Well, again, because all the crew was like kind of buzzy about it and like, hello, and like all our great friends that I would like be, I remember I was at the craft service table, not for this scene, but the next scene. And it's like, I remember going like, you know, hey, Chris, who we were like in Fancy Football, one of my favorite people,
对。我记得当时在停车场里感到非常孤独。好吧，还是因为所有的剧组人员当时都处于一种兴奋的状态，就像“嗨”，还有我们那些平时很好的朋友，我记得我当时在剧组的餐饮服务台旁，不是为了拍这场戏，而是为了下一场戏。我记得当时走过去说：“嘿，克里斯。”我们在梦幻足球联赛里是一伙的，他是我的最爱之一，
Chris Workman. And I was like, hey, Chris, and he was like, hello, John. And then like moved. And I was like, whoa, I don't think he's ever used the full word hello ever. That was the weirdest thing I've ever heard. Like everybody was so buzzed up about that. I don't remember this, Jenna, do you have any semblance
克里斯·沃克曼（Chris Workman）。我就说：“嘿，克里斯。”他的反应是：“你好，约翰。”然后就走开了。当时我就想：“哇，我觉得他这辈子都没用过‘你好’这个完整词汇吧。”那是我听过最诡异的事。每个人都因为那件事兴奋得不行。我不记得这个了，珍娜，你对我们拍了多少条还有哪怕一点印象吗？
of an idea of how many takes of that we did? Because I remember genuinely being extremely nervous, which I was like, this will be great for the scene. Because I think it was probably, or at least I had probably interpreted it as the biggest scene I had done on the show. Or something to that level of intensity was like super terrifying to me. And I remember in my head being like, hey, bro, remember when
因为我记得自己当时真心感到极度紧张，当时我想：这会对这场戏很有帮助。因为我觉得这可能，或者至少我当时把它解读为我在剧中拍过的最大的一场戏。或者说达到那种强度级别，对我来说简直是超级可怕。我记得我脑子里在想：“嘿，老兄，还记得你觉得自己是个演员的时候吗？今晚彻底毁了那种幻想。”
you thought you were an actor? Tonight ruins that whole mirage. Oh, hardly. And I was so nervous to do that scene, but actually watching it again today, it was really amazing. Because we were like kind of standing close to each other. And it was like, it was all very awkward and perfect.
哦，差远了。我当时拍那场戏时紧张得要命，但今天回看时，其实真的太棒了。因为我们俩站得比较近。那种感觉，一切都显得那么尴尬而完美。
It was so good. I wrote in my journal, oh my god. John Krasinski, win that tier. Oh my god. I have it. I'm just going to grab it and send it to you, John. Please. Oh my god.
太棒了。我在日记里写道：“哦，天哪。约翰·卡拉辛斯基，赢下那个眼泪吧。天哪。”我有日记。我这就去拿过来发给你，约翰。拜托。天哪。
You wrecked us. You wrecked me. Oh, you were so good. Both you guys were so good. I think I also remember Ken being such a good director. I was like, so in this scene, how you feeling? And how you feeling? And I was like, yeah, good.
你把我们击溃了。你把我击溃了。哦，你们俩演得太好了。我想我还记得肯是个多么优秀的导演。我当时问：“那么在这场戏里，你感觉怎么样？你感觉怎么样？”我的回答是：“挺好的。”
I said, I'm going to be really honest with you, Ken. This is a layup for me, bro, because I lived it. And he was like, what do you mean? And I was like, dude, in my high school yearbook, I have every single girl in the school being like, thank you so much. You were the shoulder to cry on. You were such a good friend when I was in love with Adam.
我对肯说：“我要跟你说实话，老兄，这对我来说简直是小菜一碟，因为我亲身经历过。”他问：“你什么意思？”我说：“老兄，在我高中的毕业纪念册上，学校里的每一个女生都对我说：‘太谢谢你了。你是我倾诉的肩膀。当我爱上亚当的时候，你是个那么好的朋友。’”
Like all this stuff, bro. I was like, no problem. So then when he was like, hey, do a scene about the love of your life having another guy instead of you. And I was like, bro, it's called my default setting. Well, I remember shivering because I was freezing. It was really cold out, and I was in that little dress.
诸如此类的话，老兄。我就说：“没问题。”所以当他提出：“嘿，拍一场关于你挚爱的人喜欢别人而不是你的戏”时，我说：“老兄，这叫我的默认设置。”好吧，我记得当时一直在发抖，因为我冻坏了。外面真的很冷，而且我穿着那件小裙子。
Yeah, that desert night. That desert night will get you. Oh, it was chilly. And I also, so here was something that I traded some messages with Ken Quapas about this scene. And he reminded me that we had actually filmed the kiss the night before. What?
对，沙漠的夜晚。沙漠的夜晚会让你领教厉害的。哦，真的很冷。而且我还……关于这场戏，我和肯·夸帕斯交流过一些信息。他提醒我，其实我们在前一天晚上就把吻戏拍了。什么？
Yeah, we filmed the kiss the day before. And that this was the very final thing we shot for Casino Night. It took longer than any other scene. We spent more time on it than any other scene. And we played around with the dialogue. So I have the script, too. And what's in the script is a little different.
对，我们在前一天就把吻戏拍了，而这是我们为“赌场之夜”拍摄的最后一个镜头。它比任何其他场景花的时间都长。我们在这场戏上花的时间比其他任何一场戏都多。我们还对台词进行了调整。我有剧本，所以我也看了。剧本里的内容稍微有点不同。
And the thing is, is that that's my memory. I remember when I think back, the scene we were most nervous about was this scene. And people always ask about the kiss, but this was the scene we worked hardest on. And it makes sense to me saying, I'm in love with you, is such a vulnerable thing. And you do it so honestly, John.
关键是，这就是我的记忆。每当我回想起来，我们最紧张的戏就是这场。人们总是问起吻戏，但这场戏才是我们下功夫最多的。我觉得这很合理，说出“我爱上你了”是一件极其脆弱的事。而你演得是那么真诚，约翰。
And I also remember that those lines where I was saying, like, oh, do you want me to take your money now? Or I could take it later. Or that was all banter that we came up with on the spot, that you were going to then shock me out of. And then I remember that stuff, that line where you said, when I'm like, I'm really sorry if you misinterpreted our friendship.
我还记得那些台词，我说的是：“哦，你想现在拿走你的钱吗？还是等会儿再拿？”或者那些全都是我们当场即兴发挥的玩笑话，目的是为了让你把我从那种情绪中震醒。然后我记得那些，你说的那句台词，当我像是在说“如果你误解了我们的友谊，我真的很抱歉”时，
And you're like, don't. When you said don't, that was an improv. And I, like, my stomach, like, my heart dropped into my stomach. I was like, oh, my god, I'm so sorry. I was like, oh, my god. That's what I love is you're doing this as Pam. And as Jenny, you're like, so sorry, bro.
你说“别这样”。当你说了“别这样”的时候，那是即兴发挥。然后我的胃……就好像我的心直接跌到了胃里。当时我想：“哦，天哪，真的非常抱歉。”我就想：“哦，天哪。”我最喜欢的就是你当时既是以帕姆的身份在演，
That was really rude. That was really rude. Like, I was having to be Pam, but on the inside, I was like, oh, sorry, because you were, you know, and you cried in a couple of the takes, I remember. But the one that they used, I think, was the first time. Like, because it was so, it wrecked me. It wrecked me.
同时作为珍娜，你在想：“真对不起啊，老兄。这也太粗鲁了。”太粗鲁了。就好像我必须扮演帕姆，但在内心深处我在想：“哦，对不起，”因为你当时，你知道的，而且我记得你在好几条拍摄里都哭了。但他们最终采用的那一条，我想是第一条。因为那感觉太真实了，把我击溃了。把我击溃了。
And I was like, my job is just stand here and stare at him. And after they yelled, cut, I feel like, I was like, oh, my god, I'm terrible. There you are saying, telling us now that you were there being like, oh, my god, I'm so sorry. And watching it back today, I was like, Jesus, cold is ice. It still holds heart in. That was cold blood.
当时我想，我的任务就是站在这里盯着他看。在他们喊“卡”之后，我觉得自己就像是在说：“哦，天哪，我太逊了。”而你呢，现在告诉我们你当时在想：“哦，天哪，真的很抱歉。”但今天回看时，我想：天啊，冷血至极。那种心狠手辣依然历历在目。简直冷血。
That was so. It was cold. But I also think Pam was just like, and listen, John, I always defend Jim throughout our podcast. And anything that happens, I'm like, Pam is horrible. Poor Jim. She does. In this moment, I really saw her as just totally.
太冷血了。但我同时觉得帕姆当时只是……听着，约翰，在我们的播客里我总是为吉姆辩护。无论发生什么，我都觉得帕姆太糟糕了。可怜的吉姆。她确实如此。但在那一刻，我真的觉得她整个人完全
She completely was deer in headlights. Like, everything was so real now. And once it's out there, it is out there, you know? And all of a sudden, she's going to have to be accountable. Yes. I felt the same way watching it back. I was like, because I remember it differently. I remember like, there were like three more moments
就像是一只在车灯前受到惊吓的小鹿。一切现在都变得那么真实。一旦它宣之于口，那就覆水难收了，你知道吗？转眼间，她将不得不承担责任。是的。我回看时也有同感。我想：因为我的记忆不太一样。我记得在“赌场之夜”里，
in Casino Night of us flirting. And then when my man turns around and is like, I want to tell you something, you're like, oh, that's so fast. Like, even me was like, hey, man, that is bad game. Stop. You know what, though, the scene that I loved was, and I realized it didn't come out of the blue, is because of Jan. And when she goes, did you tell anybody?
我们还有大约三个打情骂俏的镜头。然后当我的男主角转过身来说“我有话对你说”时，你的反应是：“哦，这也太快了吧。”甚至连我自己都在想：“嘿，老兄，这招太臭了。别说了。”你知道吗，不过我最喜欢的场景是……我意识到这并不是突发奇想，而是因为简（Jan）。当她问：“你告诉别人了吗？”
And I was like, right, he has to tell her now, because he can never do it again. That was awesome. Such good writing. Who are those people? Such good. I'm also just like so kind, like I feel like Greg and Ken, like they were so gracious to let us have room
然后我说……没错，他现在必须告诉她，因为他再也不能不说实话了。太棒了。编剧太厉害了。这些人到底是谁？太棒了。而且我也觉得……太友好了，我觉得格雷格和肯太宽容了，给我们留出了充分的空间
to find those moments, you know? Like they really let you guys play around. But me, did they write the goods right from the beginning? Yeah. We didn't need a lot of room after that. It's just so. But for those moments, they were so respectful. So, which again, leads to the second part, which is, sorry,
去寻找那些时刻，你知道吗？就像他们真的让你们自由发挥一样。但对我来说，他们从一开始就把台词写好了吗？是的。之后我们不需要太多的空间。就是这样。但对于那些时刻，他们是如此尊重。所以，这再次引出了第二部分，也就是，抱歉，
I'm jumping on your end. No, no, don't. No, no, do it. Do it. I'll move us along. But I wanted to say one more thing, which was, when I was watching it back, I was like, what does Pam think?
我打断了你的话。不，不，别。不，不，继续。继续。我来推进节奏。但我还想说一件事，那就是，当我回看的时候，我在想，帕姆在想什么？
Roy is secretly taping her or something? Like she seemed like a spy who was like, I am very sorry, but I am loyal to Roy Anderson. I can't do this. You are a wonderful friend to me. But I obviously was impacting her because we're going to move into the bullpen and she goes up and calls her mom.
罗伊在暗中录音还是怎么的？她看起来像个间谍，心里想着：“我很抱歉，但我对罗伊·安德森忠心耿耿。我不能这么做。你对我来说是个很好的朋友。”但我的确对她产生了影响，因为我们要搬到办公大厅去了，她走过去给她妈妈打电话。
To compliment your acting though, that, I mean, that has got to be my favorite thing on any performance is when it's exactly what you imagine it would be, right? Because in the movies and TV, we've been programmed as kids to say that when someone says I love you, when you're sort of with someone else, you go, excuse me, how dare you in this whole dramatic thing. But instead, your brain's just like, run the program,
不过要称赞你的演技，我的意思是，这绝对是我在任何表演中最喜欢的一点，那就是它完全符合你的想象，对吧？因为在电影和电视中，我们从小就被灌输这样一种观念：当一个人说我爱你，而你当时正和另一个人在一起时，你会说：“对不起，你怎么敢这样，”然后是一整套戏剧化的东西。但相反，你的大脑只是在想，运行程序，
shut him down, like there's no emotion. Mayday, mayday, escape. Exactly. Pull the cord, pull the cord. Should we talk about the big old kiss? It's not even a big kiss, it's a little kiss, but it's the perfect kiss. It was substantial.
拒绝他，就好像没有任何情绪一样。五月天，五月天，快逃。没错。拉绳子，拉绳子。我们该谈谈那个盛大的吻了吗？这甚至算不上一个大吻，它只是一个小吻，但它是完美的吻。它很有分量。
It's also my first kiss. First kiss I ever had acting. That was my first acting kiss ever. Mine was with Dwight. It was my second. Now that I say that, I'm wondering when else I would have had the opportunity, but like, no college play kissing, no nothing.
这也是我的初吻。我有生以来第一次演戏的吻。那是我演艺生涯中的第一个吻。我和德怀特的那次是第二个。现在我想想，我不知道自己还有什么其他机会，但没有大学戏剧里的接吻，什么都没有。
That was nothing. Wow, that was your first on-screen kiss? That wasn't your first kiss? My first big kiss. It was my second. I had done a movie called Born Champion. And I had a kiss scene in that. It was a sag low budget.
那根本不算。哇，那是你的荧幕初吻？那不是你的初吻？我的第一个大吻。那是我的第二个。我拍过一部叫《天生赢家》的电影。我在里面有一场吻戏。那是一部演员工会低成本电影。
I think maybe a non-union film. So I was one kiss more experienced than John. Which is a lot. I was so nervous. And here's something that Ken Qwapis reminded me, John. He said, let me find it, it was so sweet. Ken said, I remember the day we did the kissing scene. You and John were off the charts nervous.
我想可能是一部非工会电影。所以我的接吻经验比约翰多了一次。这可不少。我当时紧张极了。约翰，肯·克瓦皮斯提醒过我一件事。他说，让我找找，太甜了。肯说，我记得我们拍吻戏的那天。你和约翰紧张得离谱。
And he said, he felt like it was his job to be really casual about the scene, to kind of undercut how momentous it was. And I remember that he was being super casual about it. But he said, but what didn't help was that on the shooting schedule, the scene description read, Jim kisses Pam in all caps, italics, and three exclamation points.
他说，他觉得自己的工作就是对这场戏表现得很随意，以此来削弱这件事有多重大。我记得他对这件事确实超级随意。但他说，但无济于事的是，在拍摄日程表上，场景描述里写着：“吉姆吻了帕姆”，全部大写，斜体，还有三个感叹号。
This is what we train for, people. You're like, OK, jeez, come back. Oh, no, that's such a fun detail. And I think probably the crew was given the notice of like, guys, keep it cool, right? Let's not mess this up. Because that's when Chris Workman was holding a plate of peanut butter pretzels or something.
这就是我们为之训练的时刻，各位。你当时会想：好吧，天哪，冷静点。哦，不，这真是一个有趣的细节。我想剧组可能也接到了通知，类似：“伙计们，保持冷静，好吗？我们别把这事搞砸了。”因为那时克里斯·沃克曼正拿着一盘花生酱蝴蝶饼之类的东西。
He was like, hello, John. And then walked away. And I was like, Chris, what the hell was that? But I also remember you were in your trailer for a while. And I thought you were upset. Because I was on stage all the time because I was usually around crafty. And I had heard that you were in your trailer.
他说：“嗨，约翰。”然后走开了。当时我就想：“克里斯，这到底是怎么回事？”但我也记得你在房车里待了一会儿。我以为你很不高兴。因为我一直都在片场，因为我通常都在零食区附近。我听说你在房车里。
And I was like, is everything OK? And I didn't know what was happening. And then I remember, again, similarly, they told me that they were ready. And when I got on set, I was first on set at how I remember, at least. I was first on set and was looking for Randall and Matt because I used to goof around with those guys.
我就想：“一切都好吗？”我不知道发生了什么。然后我记得，同样地，他们告诉我他们准备好了。当我到片场时，据我记忆，至少我是第一个到片场的。我是第一个到片场的，在找兰德尔和马特，因为我以前经常跟那几个家伙开玩笑。
And weirdly, my default setting is like, make jokes when you're nervous. So I was looking for them. And I was genuinely crestfallen when I couldn't find them. Because then I was really nervous. Because I was like, oh my god, but if my bit machine isn't going to work, then what do we do? And then they were like, John, so you're
说也奇怪，我的默认设定就是：当你紧张的时候就讲笑话。所以我当时在找他们。当我找不到他们时，我真的沮丧极了。因为我当时真的很紧张。因为我在想：“哦，天哪，如果我的搞笑机器不管用了，那我们该怎么办？”然后他们就说：“约翰，所以你
going to go to the front door? And I was like, front door? What the hell, hey? And then I got so weirded out. And then someone came. I don't know if it was a jazz man was on yet, but I don't know. I think it was jazz came up and was like, Matt, John, go. And I was like, I just remember a person being like, and go.
要去前门吗？”我说：“前门？搞什么鬼，嘿？”然后我变得超级纳闷。接着有人来了。我不知道是不是爵士男已经上场了，但我不知道。我想是爵士过来说：“马特，约翰，开始。”我只记得有人说：“预备，开始。”
And it was like, I was in slow motion. I was like, do what? And I just went on. And it was so weird. Well, I remember rehearsing. I'm going to put that in quotes. I remember discussing the scene in the days prior. I had a bunch of meetings with Greg and you and Ken,
感觉就像我在慢动作中一样。我在想：“做什么？”然后我就上去了。感觉太诡异了。嗯，我记得排练过。我要给这个词加个引号。我记得在之前的几天里讨论过这场戏。我和格雷格、你还有肯开了很多次会，
where we all talked about it. Like, how big should the kiss be? I remember asking, how much does Pam kiss him back? We discussed that she would definitely allow herself to be kissed. And then, but did she really kiss him back? How long should it go on? Like, just sort of general, chitty
我们都在讨论这件事。比如，这个吻应该有多激烈？我记得我问过，帕姆回吻了多少？我们讨论过，她肯定会允许自己被亲吻。然后，但她真的回吻了吗？应该持续多久？就像，关于事情将如何展开的一些大致的、闲聊式的讨论。
chatness about how it would play out. And then I remember on the day doing a very rough blocking of it, but alone. Like, when you were like, what is she doing in her trailer? They had brought me to set to rehearse by myself. This is where you're going to stand at Jim's desk. There was a big discussion. Why am I not standing at reception?
然后我记得在当天的拍摄中做了一个非常粗略的走位排练，但只有我一个人。就像，当你问她在房车里做什么时？他们把我带到片场进行单人排练。这就是你待会儿要站在吉姆办公桌前的位置。这里有过激烈的讨论。为什么我不是站在前台？
It was because it would be too hard for you to get to me. They wanted to put the camera in the kitchen so that we couldn't see it. They would shoot it through the blinds. It would be super secret spy shot. And that was the best position. We worked out exactly how I would stand with the phone. And then they said, now we want you to go back to your trailer
那是因为对你来说走到我身边会太难。他们想把摄像机放在厨房里，这样我们就看不到了。他们会透过百叶窗拍摄。这将是一个超级秘密的间谍镜头。那是最好的位置。我们确切地计算好我将如何拿着电话站立。然后他们说，现在我们要你回到房车里，
and not leave until you're called. Oh, wow. And don't speak to John. And just be alone. And so it was super secret. Yes, they talk about this in the DVD commentary, guys. I wasn't there, but I listened to the DVD commentary. And they wanted to keep you guys apart.
在叫你之前不要离开。哦，哇。而且不要和约翰说话。只要一个人待着。所以这是超级机密的。是的，他们在DVD评论音轨里谈到了这一点，伙计们。我当时不在，但我听了DVD评论音轨。他们想把你们俩分开。
That's something that they talk about. My favorite thing is, I'm reminiscing about it now with you. And I remember one time talking to Brian about it years later. And I was like, oh, man, I remember that was the last thing we shot that day. And he goes, no, it was not. And I was like, what are you talking about? And he goes, we were all in our trailers like, oh, god, let's go.
那是他们谈到过的事情。我最喜欢的事是，我现在正和你在回忆这件事。我记得几年后我和布莱恩谈起这件事。我当时就说：“哦，天哪，我记得那是那天我们拍的最后一场戏。”他说：“不，根本不是。”我说：“你在说什么？”他说：“我们都在房车里想着，‘哦，天哪，我们走吧。’”
We were in our trailers for like three hours, like I took a nap. And I was like, what is happening? I know. My favorite is that that was the last thing we did that day. Me too. And Brian was like 1,000% not all of us were in our trailers being like, you've
我们在房车里待了大约三个小时，我都小睡了一会儿。我就想：“这到底是怎么回事？”我知道。我最喜欢的是，那确实是我们那天拍的最后一件事。我也是。布莱恩说百分之一千没有，我们当时都在房车里想：
got to be kidding me with these two. Oh, no. Oh, no. I thought it was the end of the day. And we had all the time in the world. That's what I said to Brian. No, he's right. But I don't know.
“这两个人真是够了，你在开玩笑吧。”哦，不。哦，不。我以为那是收工的时候。我们有的是时间。这就是我对布莱恩说的。不，他是对的。但不管怎样，
You guys, it was such an important scene. They had to find it. And in the commentary, they talk about how they wanted the first time that John, as Jim saw Pam, was in that moment on action. Yeah. So we never rehearsed it on the stage together. And then I remember they brought me to set
伙计们，这是一个如此重要的场景。他们必须找到那种感觉。在评论音轨中，他们谈到约翰饰演的吉姆第一次看到帕姆时，就是在喊“开始”的那一瞬间。是的。所以我们从未在舞台上一起排练过。然后我记得他们把我带到片场，
and all the lights were dim. There was no one around. It was super creepy. Yeah, that was creepy. Yeah, that's what I mean. So there was no crew. Nothing. And they were like, John, please move to the entrance.
所有的灯光都调暗了。周围一个人也没有。超级阴森。是的，那太阴森了。是的，这就是我的意思。所以没有剧组人员。什么都没有。他们说：“约翰，请移动到入口处。”
I was like, who is that? Is that the devil? Who just saw him? In your mind, John, it's like, slow down. Yeah, but it's super scary, like weird. And then Ken, I think, and Greg were hiding maybe in the conference room in the very back corner with a little thing, like a little handheld video monitor
我当时想：“那是谁？那是恶魔吗？刚才谁看到他了？”在你的脑海里，约翰，就像是，慢下来。是的，但这超级吓人，很诡异。然后肯，我想，还有格雷格可能躲在最里角会议室里，拿着一个小东西，比如一个小型的便携式视频监视器，
that they could see what the camera is shooting. We only used one camera. It was only the camera in the kitchen. So it was a one shot. There was no way to cut. We had to get it all in one shot. And I remember I'm doing the bit with my mom on the phone. And then you walked in and we shot the kiss.
这样他们就能看到摄像机在拍什么。我们只用了一台摄像机。只有厨房里的那一台摄像机。所以这是一个一镜到底的镜头。没有办法剪辑。我们必须一气呵成。我记得我正在电话里和我妈妈演那个桥段。然后你走进来，我们拍了那个吻。
And then we're staring at each other. And Ken said, cut. And do you remember Greg? Do you remember Greg running out of the conference room, like, clapping his hands? Yes. Yes. He was like.
然后我们互相凝视着。肯说：“咔。”你还记得格雷格吗？你还记得格雷格从会议室里跑出来，像这样拍着手吗？是的。是的。他当时就像。
He was giddy. He was like. He was like. Yes. He was like, it was so good. It was so good. It was so good. How many takes of that did we do?
他兴奋得手舞足蹈。他当时就像。他当时就像。是的。他一直在说：“太棒了！太棒了！太棒了！”我们拍了多少条？
Three. Wow. Greg only did three. I know. Greg in the DVD commentary said that he put, I'm sorry, I wrote it down. Greg said he picked the last take. The last take was his favorite.
三条。哇。格雷格只拍了三条。我知道。格雷格在DVD评论音轨里说，他选了，对不起，我记下来了。格雷格说他选了最后一条。最后一条是他的最爱。
Oh, interesting. What? Ken Quapis and Kent Zvornak both confirmed we only did three takes of the scene. And Ken said that Greg wanted to keep doing it over and over and over again. And Ken had to convince him that we had it. Wow.
哦，有趣。什么？肯·克瓦皮斯和肯特·兹沃纳克都证实，这场戏我们只拍了三条。肯说格雷格想一遍又一遍、没完没了地拍下去。肯不得不说服他，我们已经拍到了。哇。
But Greg was like, it's just so good. It's just so good. And he wanted to keep doing it. And Ken was like, no, we're going to wear him out. We're going to wear him out. That's obviously where the voice was coming from. I imagine Greg just being like, Darren's for me, and you're like, why can't you say that?
但格雷格一直说：“太棒了！太棒了！”他想继续拍下去。肯则说：“不，我们会把他们累坏的。我们会把他们累垮的。”声音显然就是从那里传出来的。我能想象格雷格当时就像是：达伦是给我的，而你却在说：为什么你不能那样说？
Awkward. Awkward. That's so weird. There's one other thing in the DVD commentary you guys, I thought was really cool, is that Randall Einhorn said that he really wanted it to end so that you couldn't see Pam's face. So you never knew what her reaction was after that.
尴尬。尴尬。这太奇怪了。DVD评论音轨里还有一件事，伙计们，我觉得真的很酷，那就是兰德尔·艾恩霍恩说他真的很想让镜头结束时看不到帕姆的脸。这样你永远不知道在那之后她的反应是什么。
That's right. So that was really thought out that, Jenna, you never looked around. Like, you were facing this one way, and Cameron never saw your face after the kiss. Yeah, that was part of what he argued for only using one camera, that there was some discussion that another camera would come around by the front door
没错。所以这是经过深思熟虑的，詹娜，你从来没有转过身来。就像，你一直面向这个方向，摄像机在吻后也再没有拍到你的脸。是的，这就是他坚持只用一台摄像机的原因之一，当时曾有人讨论过让另一台摄像机绕到前门，
and capture Pam's side of everything and sneak in. But he was like, no, I think we only managed to get one shot of this. So you don't know. It was amazing. Yeah. Crazy. It was beautiful, you guys.
捕捉帕姆那一侧的所有反应并潜入进来。但他当时说：“不，我想我们只能拍到这一个镜头。”所以你无从得知。太神奇了。是的。太疯狂了。太美了，伙计们。
You guys crushed it. Guys, this was the most fun ever to talk about this. I mean, it was fun to reminisce. You guys, guys, congratulations on this podcast. It is so much fun. And I don't think two other people could have done it. I mean, you guys do such a good job. Aw, you're so nice.
你们演得太棒了。伙计们，谈论这个真的是有史以来最有趣的一次。我的意思是，回忆过去很有趣。伙计们，祝贺你们这个播客。真的太有趣了。我不认为还有哪两个人能做到这一点。我的意思是，你们俩干得太棒了。啊，你太好了。
Thank you. Thanks so much. I don't know if there's two people from our show who like talking as much as us. Do you remember? We talk constantly. Do you remember? Brian's at home going like, we know that.
谢谢。非常感谢。我不知道我们剧组里是不是还有两个人像我们这么爱聊天。你们还记得吗？我们一直在聊天。你们还记得吗？布莱恩在家里肯定会想：我们知道了。
True. You're like, Brian, jeez. Settle down. Do you remember how Rain would make fun of us? He would say, there they go. Like, we'd be like, yeah, Rain would be like, what? More could you possibly have to say to one another? I know.
真的。你会说：“布莱恩，天哪。冷静点。”你们还记得雷恩是怎么取笑我们的吗？他会说：“他们又来了。”就像，我们会说，是的，雷恩会说：“你们俩到底还有什么可聊的？”我知道。
God. Yeah. Our crudgy, our curmudgeon. Our curmudgeon. I love you both so much. Thank you so much for doing. Thanks for having me. We love you, John.
天哪。是的，我们这个老顽固，我们的老顽固。我太爱你们两个了。非常感谢你们来。谢谢你们邀请我。我们爱你，约翰。
Thanks for coming on. That was so great. We hope you enjoyed it as much as we did. Yeah. Thank you, John. John Krasinski. You're the best. He is the best.
谢谢你来作客。真是太棒了。我们希望你们和我们一样享受这一切。是的。谢谢你，约翰。约翰·卡拉辛斯基。你最棒了。他就是最棒的。
He is the best. He is the best. But Jenna, before we say goodbye, there are one or two moments that fans wrote in about. We have to talk about the phone call between Pam and her mom. We have to talk about this moment. Yes.
他就是最棒的。他就是最棒的。但是詹娜，在我们说再见之前，粉丝们写信来提到了有一两个时刻。我们必须谈谈帕姆和她妈妈之间的那通电话。我们必须谈谈这个时刻。是的。
We got so much mail about this. Erin Louise, Matt Loveless, Mrs. Prince, Brianna, and EJ. They all wanted to know if there was another side to this phone call. Well, I'll tell you this, guys. There was no one on the other line. Jenna. I was just pretending.
我们收到了雪片般飞来的邮件。艾琳·赖伊斯、马特·洛夫莱斯、普林斯太太、布里安娜和EJ。他们都想知道这通电话的另一头到底是谁。好吧，我告诉你们吧，伙计们。电话那头根本没有人。詹娜。我只是在假装。
And the Emmy goes to Jenna Fisher. Wow. Oh, thank you. That's some good phone talk, lady. Yeah. No one was there. No one was there. I invented in my head what the dialogue was.
艾美奖得主是——詹娜·费舍尔。哇。哦，谢谢。这电话打得真好，女士。是的。根本没有人。根本没有人。我在脑海里编造了对话内容。
Yeah. And I had written it down in my script for what I thought my mom was saying to me so that I would have good reactions. And I was going through it in my head as I was doing the scene. That's me applauding my BFF. Oh, my gosh.
是的。我在剧本里写下了我以为我妈妈会对我说的话，这样我才能做出好的反应。在演这场戏的时候，我一直在脑子里过了一遍。那是我在为我最好的闺蜜鼓掌。哦，天哪。
Thank you. So there was one line in particular that everyone honed in on, which is when Pam says, yeah, I think I am. Yeah. What was she responding to? I mean, I know what I thought. I think I know what all the fans think.
谢谢。所以其中有一句台词大家特别关注，就是帕姆说：“对，我想我是。”是的。她是在回应什么？我的意思是，我知道我是怎么想的。我想我知道所有粉丝是怎么想的。
What do you think? I think I am in love with him. That is what I had written in my script that my mom asked me, well, sweetie, are you in love with him? Yeah. And that I answered, yeah, mom, I think I am. Oof. Yeah.
你觉得呢？我想我是说：“我想我爱上他了。”这就是我写在剧本里的，我妈问我：“哦，甜心，你爱上他了吗？”然后我回答：“是的，妈，我想是的。”噢。是的。
Oh, Pam. And then we got a fan question. A lot of people actually asked this question. Alyssa Dunn, Carrie Harvey, and more wanted to know if we knew what the next season would bring to the Jim Pam storyline when we shot those scenes in the parking lot and in the office. Right.
哦，帕姆。然后我们收到了一个粉丝的问题。实际上很多人都问了这个问题。艾丽莎·邓恩、凯瑞·哈维以及更多人想知道，当我们在停车场和办公室拍摄那些场景时，我们是否知道下一季会给吉姆和帕姆的故事线带来什么。对。
No, we did not. We were not told what would happen to them. It was a cliffhanger to the cast as well. I have to think that Greg probably had a few ideas and didn't want to tell us anything until it would become more concrete for him what the plan was, you know? I would think.
不，我们不知道。没有人告诉我们他们会怎么样。对演员来说这也是一个悬念。我得说格雷格可能有一些想法，但直到他对计划有了更具体的构想之前，他什么都不想告诉我们，你知道的？我想是的。
I think he had an idea that they were going to have Jim go to Stanford. Well, yeah. But a few weeks before we went back into production for the season three, I did get called in to do a bunch of chemistry read auditions with possible Karen's. Yeah.
我想他当时已经有个想法，就是让吉姆去斯坦福。好吧，是的。但在我们回剧组拍摄第三季的前几周，我确实被叫去和所有可能的“凯伦”人选一起做了一堆化学反应试读试镜。是的。
And that was my first insight into what was going to happen in season three. Oh, that's juicy. That would have been that's like good intel back then because we were all clueless. We didn't know what was going to happen. I think another cliffhanger is, you know, obviously the Dwight Angel was happening with them.
那是我对第三季即将发生的事情的最初了解。哦，这太有爆料性了。在当时这绝对是绝密情报，因为我们都一无所知。我们根本不知道会发生什么。我想另一个悬念是，你知道的，德怀特和安吉拉之间显然也有情况。
But then also what is going to happen with Jan and Michael? Because you see that Jan actually did pack an overnight bag in her car. Yes. Yes. As she's leaving, the camera finds this overnight bag. She was 100% planning to hook up with Michael. Yeah, and just sleep over at his place, which is a big deal.
但接下来简和迈克尔会发生什么呢？因为你可以看到简其实在车里收拾了一个过夜包。是的。是的。当她离开时，摄像机发现了这个过夜包。她百分之百是打算和迈克尔发生点什么。是的，而且就直接在他家过夜，这可是件大事。
Well, I did hear in the DVD commentary that it was this episode that Malora Hardin and David Denman became series regulars. So we knew that they were going to be coming back, but we didn't know how. Wow. There we go. There we go, guys.
嗯，我在DVD评论里听说，正是从这一集开始，梅洛拉·哈丁和大卫·丹曼成了常规演员。所以我们知道他们会回归，但不知道会以什么方式。哇。这就对了。这就对了，伙计们。
That was a big, big episode. We hope you enjoyed it. We certainly enjoyed getting to watch it again and talk to John and all the cast members we texted and Kintopedia. Thank you so much for giving us such great behind the scenes moments. Yes, and guys, after we did that interview with John,
那是一集非常非常重要的节目。希望你们喜欢。我们重温这部剧，跟约翰以及所有我们发过短信的演员还有Kintopedia聊天，真的非常开心。非常感谢你们给我们带来这么棒的幕后花絮。是的，而且伙计们，在我们对约翰进行那次采访之后，
Angela and I were a part of his show, Some Good News. It was so much fun. First of all, my family and I are such huge fans of Some Good News. We've watched every episode. And what John is doing, the goodness he's putting out there is so wonderful. And Jenna, wasn't it a blast?
安吉拉和我参加了他的节目《Some Good News》。太有趣了。首先，我和我的家人都是《Some Good News》的超级粉丝。我们每一集都看。约翰在做的事情、他传递的正能量是如此美好。珍娜，是不是超级好玩？
It was so much fun. If you guys haven't seen it, you have to check it out. There's this couple. Their names are John and Susan Lush. They're from Maryland. And when they got engaged, they reenacted Jim and Pam's engagement at the gas station. But then, because of the pandemic,
真的太好玩了。如果你们还没看的话，一定要去看看。有一对情侣，他们叫约翰和苏珊·拉什。他们来自马里兰州。当他们订婚时，他们在加油站重现了吉姆和帕姆的求婚场景。但是后来，因为疫情，
their May wedding was canceled. So John surprised them. We might have recreated the Dance Down the Isle from Jim and Pam's wedding. And it was just so much fun and such a wonderful thing to be a part of. Yeah, the thing that John is doing with that, it's just, it's great.
他们五月份的婚礼取消了。所以约翰给了他们一个惊喜。我们可能重现了吉姆和帕姆婚礼上从过道跳舞的场景。能参与其中真的太有趣、太美妙了。是的，约翰在做的那些事，真的太棒了。
He's bringing some light and love to the world. And John, we love you. We love you. And you guys, we will see you next week with Can You Believe It? The first episode of season three. Gay Witch Hunt. Can you believe we're on season three, Angela?
他正在为世界带来光芒和爱。约翰，我们爱你。我们爱你。大家伙儿，我们下周见，会有《你能相信吗？》。第三季的第一集。《同性恋女巫大搜捕》。安吉拉，你能相信我们已经到第三季了吗？
I can't believe it. I can't believe it. And thank you guys so much for being along with us for the ride. We will see you next week, season three. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
我简直不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。非常感谢大家一路以来对我们的陪伴。我们下周见，第三季。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium,
我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人工是因斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。若想免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，
use code, OFFICE. Thank you guys so much for being with us. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请使用优惠码 OFFICE。非常感谢大家一直以来的陪伴。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。